elon musk had a all hands-on meeting
with twitter where he answered a bunch
of questions and it's great he said he's
going to allow some pretty wacky stuff
on twitter
now we know this for a couple reasons
one there were reporters talking about
it but project veritas has leaked the
entire conversation it's really
fascinating to see a whole bunch of woke
silicon valley staffers looking at elon
musk and having to ask ask these
questions and you know they're probably
just fuming so we'll talk about that i
think that's significant because it
looks like elon musk is going to be
buying out twitter that means a lot
but we also have the ceo of rumble
joining us because we're going to talk
about rumble's rules and the changes
that are coming there and a bunch of
other really interesting stories around
the big tech censorship stuff gavin
newsom has joined truth social he wants
to hang out with donald trump i guess he
says he's going to call it their lies so
that's particularly fascinating and then
why it's so important to have free
speech usa today was caught fabricating
sources and secretly purged 23 stories
so here's what we're going to do we've
got a lot to talk about in politics for
sure this uh over in new mexico this one
county is refusing to certify the
election we'll see what happens there
what does that mean moving forward for
the midterms polls about how democrats
want trump indicted but we're going to
talk about big tech your right to free
speech why all this is so important
gavin newsom certainly thinks free
speech is important i guess not really i
don't think that and we'll be talking
about all of that stuff joining us we
got a bunch of people yeah we've got
viva fry
how's it going tim who are you uh where
do i look at this camera right there yes
viva ferrari montreal litigator uh
content creator robert and i have an
awesome locals community
vivabarnslaw.locals.com
uh been working with rumble to
actually tinker with some terms of use
for free speech
that is going to be clear transparent
and actually change the way people look
at what it means to actually have a
platform that respects free speech right
on we got robert barnes absolutely glad
to be here uh here to discuss the way
that the new rumble rules will not only
revolutionize the way free speech can
work on the internet but be a open
source that people can utilize create a
participatory process so both content
creators and consumers can be involved
in the process it's a way that big tech
can move forward in the uh a way that
promotes and protects the original goal
of a free and open internet right on and
of course to really help us understand a
lot of this is the ceo of rumble himself
chris pavlovsky thanks for having me on
looking forward to being on here tonight
this uh this whole change that we've
done is actually inspired from the
community here at uh tim castro
so
you know if i wasn't here uh six months
ago i don't know if this would have
happened but uh seeing all the feedback
and uh
what the community is looking for i
think uh
we're we're doing the right thing here
and uh i'm excited to be here to
to propose what we want to do cool we
got luke super excited about today's
conversation my name is luke dawski of
we are change.org today i'm wearing one
of my tamer t-shirts that
i think the the canucks should
definitely understand well here and it
says you cannot comply your way out of
tyranny if you like the shirt and you
want to get it and support me you can on
thebestpoliticoshorts.com because you do
i'm here it's going to be a great
conversation no machetes this time chris
i promise
and thank you so much for having me and
i'm also here in the corner not
expecting to talk a lot tonight but very
excited to hear what everyone has to say
before we get started my friends head
over
to
eatrightandfeelwell.com and pick up your
keto elevate from biotrust
c8mct oil powder that means medium chain
triglycerides it is no secret my friends
if you go back to i think like september
october and watch these shows i was much
fatter i've actually lost almost 30
pounds crazy i've been doing keto heck
yeah i started doing keto and then i
started uh putting in a little bit more
carbs so now i'm mostly just very low
carb i'm basically doing keto this
stuff's fantastic i love putting up my
coffee put some heavy cream put some uh
bio trust in there
eatrightandfeelwell.com
you can get a 60-day money-back
guarantee keto elevate provides your
body only c8 the most ketogenic mct that
means it provides support for energy
levels healthy appetite management
mental clarity and focus athletic
performance keto elevate personally my
favorite mct and i yes i actually have
tried some other ones and i wasn't a big
fan it's it's probably not a coincidence
that we like them so much
you'll get free shipping on every order
and for every order today biotrust
donates a nutritious meal to a hungry
child in your honor through their
partnership with no kid hungry.org to
today biotrust has provided over 5
million meals to hungry kids please help
biotrust hit their goals of 6 million
meals this year you'll get free vip live
health and fitness coaching from
biotrust team of expert nutrition and
health coaches for life with every order
and their free e-report the top 14
ketogenic foods with every order i'll
tell you this i cut out sugars started
eating a bunch of this stuff i lost a
lot of weight it mostly was just cutting
out the sugar but if you buy at
eatrightandfeelwell.com they're going to
give you the adequate advice and
information you need so check them out
we're big fans and we really do
appreciate the sponsorship biotrust but
don't forget to also head over to
timcast.com and become a member
support our work directly and you'll be
supporting our journalists i also just
realized this too i never say my name on
the show not once really yeah whenever
when everyone everyone does
introductions looks like i'm luke
wadowski and ian's like i'm me and
crossland i never say my name
so i'm like that's who you are you don't
need to know my name i guess you know if
you watch the show people are like
what's this guy's name they know my name
is tim i suppose
so uh go to timcast.comwork not only
will you get access to exclusive
segments from this show monday through
thursday at 11 pm which we'll have up
for you tonight you will also be
supporting our journalists who work hard
to get you true and fact check
information every day you're also
supporting our infrastructure because we
use rumble
for our cloud infrastructure and our
video hosting why because we want to
help build a space outside of big tech's
grip on on everything be more resilient
to censorship and so we have a lot of
other stuff uh we're working on the
background i often mention but uh
support companies that are that are
trying their best to to help build
something uh differently build something
that's more resilient to the censorship
which is why we have this conversation
set up as we do today but let's get
started with this news about elon musk
don't forget smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends here's the big news
from project veritas
exclusive twitter all hands meeting from
june 16th the amazing thing is this
meeting just happened and then project
veritas is like we had the meeting
literally the moment and ended leaked
video of elon musk's address to twitter
employees about essential nature of free
speech voting republican and evolving
twitter quote i think it's essential to
have free speech musk said on the call
after describing his affinity for
twitter he added multiple opinions
should exist on twitter to make sure
that we are not sort of driving a
narrative on the call musk was asked
about his political leanings his plans
for layoffs in the direction of the
company he described himself as moderate
noting that he traditionally has voted
democrat by voter republican this week
for the first time in his life
he also discussed his vision for twitter
saying that traditional news media is
negative and they almost never get it
right he added that bots spam and
multi-account users must be contained i
think an important goal for twitter
would be to try to include as much of
the country as much of the world as
possible he knows that he's not hung up
on titles he reacted the news of project
veritas publishing the recorded meeting
on twitter by posting exactly in fact he
was responding to lydia that's right he
was i was so excited the guy from
project veritas actually called me i was
in target picking out a birthday card
and he's like what are you doing i was
like i'm picking out a birthday card
he's like oh so you didn't see that elon
musk tweeted at you and i was like
that's so cool i was freaking out in
target
so i can only imagine the woke twitter
employees who were lamenting libs of
tick tock must be particularly irked
having to sit there and listen to elon
musk be like i think we should have free
speech and put wacky stuff on this
platform
did elon musk not know that it was being
recorded because if there's one meeting
and given the content of what was leaked
you would say certain things knowing
that it might be leaked afterwards
although this like is a great thing to
always just take for granted everyone's
recording everything you say at all
times so you don't say anything dumb
yeah uh shocking so shocking that you
have gavin newsom now looking for the
other free speech platform because they
they support free speech somewhere just
not where they don't want to hear it
that's so weird though it's like
yeah so that's that's another story
we'll get into but
what's the logic behind opposing free
speech or being uh you know california
has got a lot of skeletons in its closet
pertaining to big it's california and
now it's like i'm going to go on truth
social
i i'm just wondering uh you know it's
it's amazing that they leak the meeting
right after it's done but those are some
good talking points
the odds are elon musk is the source
i think a very big one especially from
the corporate media's response to this
because according to their sources and
according to the twitter slack the
employees are very angry and they're
very pissed off and they don't know how
to deal with this larger acquisition
which they have voiced
you know that they were disappointed
with so elon musk just a few days ago
even talked about how twitter is biased
against half the country how they're
inactive against death threats against
conservatives he just voted for a
conservative for the first time in his
life he also
hinted that he's going to be voting for
ron desantis in 2024 so obviously uh
what he said wasn't controversial but
for the people working at twitter for
the people in san francisco for the
yuppy starbucks drinking flip-flop
wearing yuppies there holy cow their
minds are probably going crazy and
they're freaking out because this is
this is the reckoning of a big social
media platform that's going to change
the game but this is funny the twitter
employees are outraged over this there
they've been complaining about elon
musk's takeover we have the leaked chats
where they're talking about banning libs
of tick tock and it's like they don't
seem to realize they are the snowflakes
in the avalanche of people like elon
musk voting republican it is the actions
they have taken with censorship with
their hostility and intolerance that's
resulting in elon musk being like i
don't think you're fun so i'm going to
vote for this other guy i'm going to go
read the babylon b they must be thinking
if only we banned the babylon b elon
musk would still vote democrat what's
encouraging about it is that clearly not
everyone within twitter is so much on
board with the nonsense and it's it's a
vocal minority who purport to represent
the majority
and they're going to find out at one
point sooner than later it's not going
to be cool to do this because people are
going to want an actual platform that
actually just allows people to talk not
in hurtful hate you know violent ways
openly to share ideas i gotta say truth
social is not bad
so when when i i ragged on it because
when they first launched i couldn't even
get in it and i was just like but they
what i mean by that is you know i don't
think i'm deserving of anything special
but i was reached out someone reached
out to me and they were like hey can we
get you on i was like sure and then i
couldn't get on i was like this is dumb
i don't know what's going on like it's
just so disorganized and then someone
had at tim cast and it was like a parody
account and i was like i didn't care but
then i lost i i i heard it was like
number one in the app store and so i
checked and the engagement is crazy and
i was like whoa
people are on truth social and they're
having conversations like more so than
twitter
so i'm thinking to myself
if people use twitter because the
conversation's happening there but now
it's not and they're just trying to
destroy your life because you tweeted a
joke or retweeted a joke like dave
weigel at the washington post yo you
might also just be on truth social or
somewhere somewhere else i think elon
sees this as why he's desperately trying
to salvage this well elon made public
statements about this he said that it's
the failures failures of twitter that
led donald trump to create truth social
that it's bringing people there and it's
also he also makes the argument that
censorship is radicalizing individuals
as of course it's pushing people off to
further points of the internet it's now
not allowing a real honest discussion
it's it's making people's views uh be
double downed on instead of questioned
and that conversation used to happen on
twitter it's not anymore um and and
we're seeing again just the
the politization the this kind of
radicalization of people from both
political parties that are are going
further and further from away from each
other and i think that's because of big
tech social media i think twitter
specifically i think twitter created
this rage cycle where
i knew i knew this guy i'm not gonna say
his name he's a reporter normal guy who
used to hang out
one day he he replied to donald trump
something like oh shut up and he got
like a 100 retweets all of a sudden he
went from having a couple hundred
followers to having a thousand followers
oh the dude destroyed his life and
career he became a trump reply guy
and then he ended up getting you know
tens of thousands of followers and i
said yeah but who's gonna hire you now
what are those followers good for but it
felt good it was an addiction
no that's it that's what people did they
drove themselves off a cliff
no i don't have a truth handle yet maybe
i'll uh have to look if the engagement
in the discussion is there it's uh but i
i actually as far as twitter goes i
enjoy the discussion and the engagement
with people with whom i disagree
ideologically it's the amazing thing
about uh sharing ideas and and and
fighting in the political sense
well gavin's there now so
i still enjoy picking on gavin on
twitter but he hasn't yet to recognize
you know what i really like doing is i
like responding to far leftists but in
agreement so it's like
they'll tweet something that i agree
with and i'll make sure i'm going to
respond with an agreement or adding to
their point because that's my point i'm
like i don't hate him you're like i'm
not just going to respond to someone for
the sake of being like you're wrong
about that one i'm gonna respond
specifically only when i think they're
right about something and then it's
funny how their friends react and
they're like
you know no tim pool should not be
agreeing with us and i'm like well you
know i do so
do something about it i guess
yes super double reverse uh cancellation
if you agree with the people then their
friends have to cancel them oh yeah yeah
and there's something i call bugs
bunnying you know you know how bugs
bunny did the duck season rabbit season
back and forth you know that bit
you know how this one uh all right so
you got don you got daffy duck and you
got bugs bunny and daffy is saying it's
rabbit season and pulling the sign off
the tree and then bugs says it's duck
season and pulls to sign up the tree and
elmer fudd is standing there like who am
i gonna shoot because he's a hunter and
then bugs at the last minute flips it
and he goes it's rabbit season and then
daffy goes no no no it's duck season and
then bugs goes if you say so then elmer
fudd shoots daffy instead
so when you agree with them
they have to disagree with you if
they're tribalists so then all of a
sudden you'll find these like
progressives on the side of the fascists
or whatever because you know do uh
robert do we know like is elon gonna get
the company for a lesser price have they
resolved the bot issue yet that has not
been resolved and so we'll see i mean
the question is what happens to truth if
elon musk takes over twitter and really
returns it to its free speech what do
you think chris i think that you have a
completely different audience on on
truth than you do on on twitter i think
these are completely different two
different audiences and i don't think
there's much overlap in it so when
if elon ever does get a hold of twitter
i think that audience is already gone
and they were never they're never coming
back i agree
i think i think it might be too late i
think the segmentation of these
platforms is upon us yeah i mean donald
trump even said if he gets invited back
on twitter he's not going to come back
because he has truth social uh but there
also has been accusations against truth
social with censorship against people
posting january 6th information uh
that's some of the alleged information
coming out within the last couple days
and there is something as barnes as you
brought up to the larger point of if
twitter does take over and allow free
speech on their platform people are
saying it's predominantly going to
affect donald trump and shoot social the
most out of all the other platforms well
i think that's where there needs to be
what rumble is doing is the right way to
go which is to create clear transparent
open roles honestly getter kind of
didn't well i won't be critical of
anyone else just say no one else has
created the rules that rumble is going
about creating not only creating those
rules but also creating a participatory
process whereby consumers and creators
can be part of that process create rules
that can be open source that can be
mimicked and mirrored and copied by
getter by truth by gab by
anyone else by twitter if elon musk
purchased it and because these are rules
are designed to reach a balance between
not making it a troll heavy platform but
at the same time making it as free for
speech and expression as possible that
heresy and dissident speech is allowed
and that's what people wanted in the
original free and open internet and
rumble's been taking the lead at
creating open transparent rules to make
that a reality
should we talk about the initiatives now
i mean i'm excited about what you guys
got wrong because last time we had we
had we had some very interesting
conversations with a lot of other social
media platforms here on this uh podcast
uh we had a we had a very interesting
conversation with chris six months ago
so you know should we should we go there
or or should we wait for later to talk
about these developments so let's do
this let me pull up uh something a bit
more political and then we'll get into
why this stuff is so important
this is a story from the new york times
usa today to remove 23 articles after
investigation into fabricated sources
the articles were removed after
investigation identified stories and
sources that appeared to be fabricated
usa today said the internal
investigation which took place over a
period of several weeks began after usa
today received an inquiry related to the
veracity of details in an article by
gabriela miranda who was a breaking news
reporter at usa today all right
i'm gonna pull up uh usa today real
quick
so one of the leading fact check news
organizations in the country has been
spreading false news and fake news for
and here's the best part interesting
news guard gives them a 100 out of 100
wow
and they've been they've actually been
fabricating stories so my question to
newsguard is why did you certify an
organization that was fabricating
stories outright tim
they got it they took them down now so
they fact checked their own fact checks
and determined they were factually
incorrect so they get they should get
101. like uh
there's not fact checking there was just
gulagging they were deleted
23 articles were deleted here's my point
new usa today publishes fake articles
newsguard looks at them and says those
are real why because usa today said so
usa is the fact check they fact check a
bunch of stuff that we say is bogus
fact-checking but you get called a
conspiracy theorist for calling out the
bogus fact-checkers
okay i get fact-checked for the most
ridiculous stupidest things especially
when it comes to memes by these
institutions and and again another thing
to to kind of understand here go on
their website it should be front page
news on their website right now hey guys
we lied to you hey guys we fabricated
stories hey guys if this was me it is it
is it is it is january where it's top
headline yep there it is there it is
thank goodness all right good thank
goodness all right finally uh but but it
should have been like so sorry we goofed
up we messed up we lied to you uh and
this is a full transparency and
accountability of what actually happened
but hold on if you back it up just one
second um i still saw january 6 first i
saw that too
that's not front page i mean they should
stop running news they should stop
putting out articles they should
apologize get on their knees to the
general public and said i'm so sorry i
lied to you but they don't that's what
anyone with any kind of reputation
should be doing right now because this
is so embarrassing and this is not
something that's uncommon this happens a
lot there's a lot of reporters doing
this brian williams another person who
did this
very publicly this is why
free speech is so important it's obvious
i mean obviously free speech is
important for
a million and one reasons that we cannot
we talk about in terms of your right to
go outside and speak your mind or your
right to uh practice the religion you
you want i'm speaking more broadly than
just the first amendment i mean quite
literally you're right to say these
things about what you believe and uh on
your politics but it's also
your ability to share the news on these
social media platforms and when the news
broke of censorship against
conservatives it was may of 2016 and it
was gizmodo i believe who said that
facebook uh moderators for the trending
tab were deleting conservative sources
from their trending news section because
they believed conservative sources were
fake news
that was it
now we have newsguard
which is uh uh one of their big clients
i believe is microsoft bill gates
and they they they like to certify or
these news outlets now i like i i like
it i like the idea and so we we i make
sure all of our sources are always going
to have that nice green check mark but i
will not hesitate to point out that
their system is completely broken and
makes no sense
particularly because
how does usa today have a 100 out of 100
if they are publishing fake news
how do fact checkers know whether or not
a story from music today is real or fake
if the new york times cnn or usa today
come out with a story and say
john smith told us he sold a boat for a
hundred dollars they would say it's true
because usa today said so
see that's not fact checking
they just say
these you know newsguard for instance
totally biased in that we just assumed
usa today was right
no they should be down ranked completely
and they should be forced to jump
through hoops legal audits if they want
to get their green check mark back they
should be fired they shouldn't have a
job
well the reporter i think is getting
fired
the whole institution for allowing it in
my opinion well
the problem is there shouldn't be these
gatekeepers in the first place i mean
platforms shouldn't be gatekeepers they
shouldn't be labelers and that's where
rumble is taking the right direction
think about how irresponsible that is
like imagine putting a ceo of a tech
company to assign other companies or
other entities or other people to say
what's right or what's wrong
like
what's true or or what's fiction i mean
you look at who am i to do that but it's
ridiculous it's the it's the circular
nature of it is that they they use their
own bill gates having any hand in this
whatsoever is already super sus as the
children say but
they use these to discredit the other
independent voices to then raise their
own voices to prominence so they can
remove who's the journalist it's like a
version of russiagate where you where
you use your own laundry information
over and over again as sources and
citations so you have a bogus source
come in and then they leak to the press
that the investor fbi is investigating
it and then they use the press to get a
fisa warrant and then they use that fact
to justify it to congress there's a
there's a list that came out today of
prominent people who have sowed uh doubt
about the election now what does that
mean to so doubt about the election it
means nothing literally nothing you
could say something like wow look at
this story about the election that's
dumb and they'll say oh but by sharing
it you so doubt whether i was in so i
made the list
yeah i'm very excited but here's the
reason they do it
there are organizations that fundraise
off of this there are news outlets that
publish the lies
they need some kind of legal
justification so that i can't sue them
so someone will make an opinion
statement tim poole so doubt about the
election how did he do it he reported on
a new jury you knew a story in new
jersey about an election that had to be
redone due to them finding a bundle of
ballots in a mailbox true story
oh but that means tim poole is sowing
down on the election so we're going to
put you on that list now news outlets
can all report the more extreme version
they can launder that information and
say tim poole
published or pushed lies
then when i come back and say that's not
true they'll say i was just referencing
this study and that was my
interpretation of it
good luck suing it's happening on a
smaller scale to me in canada but ctv w5
runs a story a hit piece on rumble
refers to it as a the darling of the
right-wingers where you go to post
covered misinformation they then
demonize me on that show to make me look
like i'm responsible for one cherry
picked
let's call it a bad comment
the story goes uh publishes wikipedia
then i noticed some people editing over
my wikipedia to say it's time we get
real with viva's right wing extremism w5
showcased him and then i noticed another
article from the simon fraser institute
talking about disinformation on the
internet that google doesn't
auto-complete when you look up alex
jones it says author and not conspiracy
theorist and they think that's a problem
and i was in the appendix that when you
look up viva fry it doesn't say right
wing covert conspiracy theorist it just
says nothing it's the wrap up smear on a
fake news level i want to add to that
real quick so i'll put it put a pin in
that loop when google glass came out it
was very it was it was very prominent
because you could say you know okay
google tell me this and it would talk to
you you'd say
what is the capital of uh new york the
capital of new york is albany and then
they'll give you some facts so we get
this thing and so you know i'm hanging
out loot and i go
okay google who is tim poole and it goes
tim poole is an award-winning journalist
from chicago illinois and then i go okay
google who is luke rutkowski and it just
literally goes conspiracy theorist
that's it i was going to make that point
i'm i'm happy you did before me i was
going to say that well i was originally
going to say i think everyone in this
room has been slandered has been
attacked had the media just make up
stories about them i mean i had my name
run through the mud they were just
making stuff up out of just thin air but
but just let's let's think about this
story from usa today what would happen
if if one of us did what usa today did
what would happen if an independent
media organization ran 23 fake stories
that they just totally made up we would
not be here we would we would we would
be hearing about this luke for years to
come can i pause you real quick
do you really think it was just 23
stories this is what we know from their
own independent audit this is like the
police investigating the police which is
questionable
there's a reason bill gates puts
hundreds of millions of dollars into
media companies there's a reason that
social media algorithms promote these
trusted news sources that lie about
almost every single thing and and i
think even elon musk made this point
today saying that predominantly almost
everything that the corporate media
tries to sell is is a lie not all of it
but a lot of most of it um and and i
think it's fair to say that especially
with the way that our society has been
abused and used by the special interests
that corporate media is just pr for the
ruling establishment and it's nothing
else and this is a perfect example of
how they play by a whole different set
of rules when we get criticized we get
slandered we get lied about and we get
attacked and vilified for trying to even
speak up against this bull crap politico
is a really interesting organization i
don't understand how their news guard is
certified which which makes me question
newsguard itself
politico has
we we've showed these stories before
they have numerous stories contradicting
their own reporting
one story is from january of 2017 that
says uh something like you know ukraine
panics
uh assisting democrats in the 2016
election is backfiring or something to
that effect the argument the story was
basically that ukraine tried helping
clinton to stop trump and when trump won
it was bad news for him they then wrote
a few years later that is actually
russian disinformation that ukraine
helped the democrats and both stories
are still live on politico how could
how could you say
look if that was the only thing let's
let's say out of the other 500 000
stories or whatever on that website
they're all true and correct but those
two exist you'd immediately have to say
as a rating agency you are being
stripped of being a credible agency
because you have two articles that acute
that both say both stories are false i'm
gonna ask a stupid question is new york
times news guard certified oh 100 okay
there's still an article up there that
says he dreamed of being a capital
police officer then a group of pro-trump
mobsters killed him brian sicknick that
article is still up wow and
one of the books that robert has
recommended on our locals community uh
the gray lady winked you realize it's
it's not a one-off it's
institutionalized it's been this way for
the last 70 years they got it wrong on
the homolodor they got it wrong
they got it wrong on world war ii they
got it wrong on hiroshima they got it
wrong uh on the um the palestinian boy
that was that was killed in the first
intifada it's a history it's a pattern
it's not about consistency it's about
hierarchy it's not a mistake it's just
the way
that's it
the only thing is we're now able to fact
check and call it real time and then and
then if we make one mistake we get uh
not not just blacklisted you'll get
de-platformed if anyone had done one of
these stories they would be
de-platforming oh you'd be banned from
google news instantly they would never
show your website again
for the longest time this show didn't
appear on google search it's the
craziest thing it's like we're on
youtube then one day it was funny i
called him out on the show and then
people were like yo you're back on
google like someone watching at google
was like let's put them back in there
and
loaded us back up
but it's remarkable that
google is the way people find
information
over 90 yeah you'll you'll go you'll you
open the browser bar and you type in
word i don't even type in web addresses
anymore i'll just type in you know like
what did i just do i typed in usa today
and press enter and then it went to
google
if google removed usa today for being
fake news wouldn't come up was a very
good suit against the bite
administration brought by the states of
arizona louisiana that goes through and
in their motion for preliminary
injunction details the degree of
government collusion that's been taking
place even under trump's administration
he didn't know his own department of
homeland security his own cyber
institute uh cyber security folks were
already manipulating information
including suppressing information
hostile to biden and favorable to trump
and they've only escalated that that's
why bobby kennedy's suit against
facebook is so important before the
ninth circuit court of appeals currently
pending but this has also been
government-created government-curated
censorship for the purposes of
controlling the information in the
narrative and that's why they fear big
tech and independent to any kind of
challenge to big tech monopoly is a
threat to their gatekeeping control over
the institutional narrative and they are
monopolies you characterize them
absolutely very correctly for those
people out there that think monopoly
means 100 it doesn't it means 75 or more
historically in american law and this is
over 80 percent google as you're
mentioning over 90 of all searches
controlled by google almost all news
information that's sought or see or that
is read or reviewed or heard is uh
dominated by google but robert respond
to the argument that people are going to
say it's a merit-based monopoly they've
gotten it because of a superior product
none of that's true the antitrust
litigation details that i mean the there
is some degree that to which this
technology naturally and climbs itself
to monopoly in the way peter thiel talks
about but by no means did they actually
obtain this monopoly twitter obtained it
because they said we're going to be the
free speech wing of the free speech
party they just lied that's what they
did that's what google did that's what
youtube lied youtube said hey we welcome
all content creators we're never going
to censor anybody and they became one of
the biggest sensor uh centers in the
entire globe and they keep changing
their terms and services as you go along
so you agree to one you invest all of
your your time your energy your blood
sweat and tears into a business and then
they say you know what we're just going
to blacklist you because you challenged
the narrative you questioned the agenda
so we're going to demonetize you down
rank you and make sure that you can't
work on the internet at all which is the
power that they have which is absolutely
insane and way too much power for one
organization to have here's here's where
i think it's the most important thing is
i think for all of us we've got
platforms or literally run one and so
the problems we face are particularly
unique don't exist in the general
population
but for the average person who does
choose to get on twitter and say i would
like to speak my mind and challenge this
they're the ones who get banned first
when learn to code was happening when
they were banning people for saying
hashtag learn to code majority of the
people who are getting banned were like
small counts people who were just you
know posting it the big channels were
less likely to get banned this is on
purpose they don't want to create a
splash but there are so many people i've
met and spoken with who say i can't i
went on i was on twitter for two days
and i posted a news story and they
banned me i hear it all the time now
think about what that means twitter will
say
if they're on the left
give some leeway if they're on the right
don't give them the time of day so when
right wing people come on or libertarian
moderate write whatever you want to call
it come on the platform and say here's
the real story with a link to a source
debunking something they're banned
instantly
if you ban 60 of them but only 40 of the
left if anyone at all you create this
lopsided system where the majority of
information coming out will be narrative
controlled fake news
and the people who know know better are
unable to counter it that's why we need
elon musk you're right over the target
with this one it's the long tail that
got banned that no one's talking about
it's the the people at the top they were
tougher to ban but the long tail really
got banned it shifted the whole system
tilted it everywhere this is why i think
you this is why i think like platforms
like truth have a completely different
uh audience
you go ahead sorry no that that's that's
excuse perception and reality especially
if you're able to get rid of that tale
as you perfectly described here because
there has been a full frontal assault on
independent thought independent media
and critical thinking if you just go if
you dare to even just go against the
establishment and what they want you to
believe at that current time at that
current moment even though it flip-flops
uh by the interest whoever's involved in
it you are are done with you are not
going to have a way to succeed or live
online but now there's alternatives now
there's truth there's rumble there's
getter there's uh
hive there's steemit there's so many
other different alternative different
platforms out there
there's hive there's so many different
ones out there it's also meant to tell
you as an independent person that your
view doesn't count that you've your view
is wrong so that little person that
ordinary person that everyday person
doesn't have lots of followers gets on
and has a distant information about
covet dissident information about the
election fornication that took place in
2020 has dissident information about
ukraine they're told your view is not
only disapproved not only unsanctioned
but it's wrong and nobody really agrees
with you and that's why you're being
censored that's why you're being
sanctioned that's why you're being
disapproved of and that's why it's
critical that there be tech challenges
to this whether it's locals whether it's
rumble whether it's true and i'll say
we're going to get into this with the
rumble terms of terms of use
discussion but the learn to code the the
rationale at the time if everyone
remembers it it was it was deemed
something of a call to violence it was
deemed to be harassment learn to code
for the journalists who mocked uh middle
america when they said well we're losing
our jobs and they said learn to code and
when the journalists started losing
their job they said learn to code oh
when we said it too it was loving you
know a a needle when you say it to us
it's a call to violence it's it's it's
weaponizing and bastardizing the terms
for political purposes let's talk about
gavin newsom real quick oh yeah we have
this from the hill newsome joins trump's
truth social to call out republican lies
this is actually quite uh quite amazing
he says quote i just joined tr trump's
truth social going to be on there
calling out republican lies this could
get interesting my first post breaking
down america's red state murder problem
he said adding a link to his truth
social post yeah i know like urban
centers are all in you know blue cities
but um here's the funny thing
twitter bans their way to irrelevance
and now prominent prominent democrats
like i better go over here
to engage in this conversation
this is his second self own in as many
months i think he tried to poke fun at
um
why is it a cell phone because he's
basically admitting that he doesn't
support free speech on the one hand on
the twitter platform but does support it
and wants to flock to it on another
platform yeah this is the same guy who
tweeted out
a mocking photo of desantis he was
reading books that desantis was banning
not realizing that the same dude in
california are banning books he doesn't
understand a cell phone when it happens
but thank goodness that he he gives it
to the public could it be
that the democrats
the the the leftists of big tech who've
banned these conservatives have created
a boring platform and now democrats are
going to want to go to truth social what
if it turns out that twitter ends up
dying elon buys it and everyone's like
well but twitter's so last election
trump truth social is funny because
trump's on there and we all want to know
about it these journalists are going to
have to report on what trump truths
is that what it's called he's true thing
he's true so when trump when trump
truths
that's an amazing thing to say by the
way
journalists have to have accounts to see
what he's saying
forcing them to sign up and be on the
platform then what's the point of being
on twitter it's not it's gonna be it's
not gonna be newsworthy anymore the
people are gonna be on truth and trump's
gonna control it now you're on his
platform baby is that where we're going
it's going to be interesting to see if
trump censors uh gavin he's not going to
sense no
it would be it would be stupid for him
to do it but it wouldn't surprise me you
know what might happen gavin might get
his butt handed to him on truth and he
might actually say holy crap california
is not doing well in a great many
respects he might actually see the truth
on truth
wouldn't that be ironic this warrants
like some kind of sketch where gavin's
like i'm joining truth a week later he's
wearing a maga hat
because i've seen the light you hear the
story about these moderate content
moderators and feds that when they go on
facebook and they join these groups they
end up getting radicalized and they're
you know i they call it radicalization
in the media but i'm like perhaps the
moderator is seeing like real news
stories that normally get removed and
they're not getting the filtered
narrative anymore and so they're going
like whoa well that's the whole point of
strategic empathy used to be you taught
in the state department military you
have strategic empathy for your enemy or
adversary but the question is why don't
we teach it anymore in the u.s state
department well what happens if your
strategic empathy leads you to be more
pathetic to that perspective and all of
a sudden you can't hate say russia or
putin or somebody else around the world
you can't despise them anymore because
you've learned to understand them and so
we've we've uh taught teaching it so
that people don't do it and what big
tech is trying to do is to not even let
you have access to it because once you
do people end up opening their mind to
different perspectives especially over
the last i mean basically you look at
every alex jones conspiracy theory from
five years ago and we've lived them over
the last five years in some form and so
all of a sudden people re uh uh perceive
alex jones in a whole different light
they can't afford that to occur that's
why they need people to never listen or
hear that information the first place
this censorship is about controlling the
audience not just the listener and i
think that's what people forget about
the first amendment the first
amendment's not only the right to speak
it's the right to listen it's the right
to hear
testify that's actually
quite beautiful robert
it's actually crazy to think that
silicon valley executives could
determine what you could listen to what
you could uh be able to think about and
that level of power is godlike
let me ask you a question have you ever
watched a video that you thought was
like the best video ever and you want to
show your friends and then you're like
watch this watch if you you play it and
as you're sitting there they're not
reacting to it and you're like they
don't like it this is really awkward and
like they're not laughing at it
zuckerberg or any one of these tech
people could could it's not just about
negative it's not it's not about
censorship they could be like this
message should be put out they could go
in and force you to watch these things
no absolutely you know the thing that
kills me though
is i've been in this space for like 20
years and i remember these guys they're
all talking about the free and open
internet we love like free speech
matters and then all of a sudden in five
years what happened to these people
like it was was this just [ __ ] for
the last 20 years like how do they just
flip like that like i
i sit and i sit in this chair now and
i'm like i can't [ __ ] flip like that
i can't swear i don't know what it is
we try not to but look when when when
the when the lizard people came down and
implanted the brain slugs and took over
their minds i'm kidding by the way but
uh
that's gonna be in usa today tomorrow
well i had this discussion with
twitter's lawyers in 2016. because i was
uh suing for charles johnson who has you
know eclectic history but the against
twitter and twitter at that point at
least jack dorsey was serious about the
very same rules that rumble's talking
about now putting in those kind of rules
codify the existing law that will
protect that you know there's no first
amendment protection for stalking or
defamation or doxxing in these things
anyway that they were claiming they were
worried about and it ultimately didn't
go through and the impression i got is
the investors that invested i don't
think dorsey was fully gung-ho behind
all the censorship that took place
you're seeing that in his alignment with
elon musk now but i think for the most
part they went on trump
trump winning wasn't supposed to happen
you have the authority
like i can't
there's no excuse and i look at them and
i'm like
they all capitulated to the pressure of
investors george soros publicly said he
was going to go after uh facebook i mean
this is a guy who helped sink the
british crown saudi arabia and also you
got to understand elon musk buying
twitter has started uh people like with
the with the clintons the obamas and and
uh bill gates throwing secret money into
shadowy funds attacking twitter trying
to get advertisers off of the platform
and coordinated attacks particularly
when the takeover is going to be
complete so there's a lot of power a lot
of money behind the scenes that are
influencing
a lot of things that we don't know about
but but again
as you said i i i kind of agree with you
more it's it's on him but he was facing
a lot of pressure we have that every day
yep right now like i'm not going to
capitulate to that yeah i i'm more
empathetic i don't think they
capitulated i think they genuinely think
they are suppressing freedom of speech
to guarantee freedom of speech i think
they've actually convinced themselves
they need to do this in order to create
a platform that's welcoming for
everybody if you have an open debate
about trans
sports activities it's going to make
people feel unsafe to talk and they need
to limit the freedom of speech in order
to promote the freedom of speech it's
it's orwellian uh
lunacy but i believe they actually
believe it well it's it's
this is
i think i think one way to put it is
they're anti-meritocratic
and the conversations that rise to the
top that dominate or the information
that does
they don't want to
so if you say something like two plus
two equals four
it's not so much that they're
they're threatened by it because they
don't like it it's not it's not the idea
they want they don't want an individual
to rise up through merit and hard work
and good arguments they want to control
those arguments they want to control
those narratives
so they need to eliminate that that
element of it yeah the problem is
there's way too many control freaks
there's way too many bill gates types
just so control control control you know
you dig into gates
go by politico 2017 politico's european
union
organization who says bill gates is
getting way too much power and influence
in the public health world these are
public health whistleblowers then they
disown their own peace by 2020 when alex
jones and others are saying bill gates
agenda is going to be reflected on a lot
of public health agendas around the
world and we actually saw it happen we
saw event 201 become a reality around
the globe um it's because they
ultimately there's too many control
freaks and positions of power in big
tech and stock and now we have something
called the bill chill where a lot of
scientists are afraid to even criticize
anything associated with bill gates or
his money or his investments whether
it's fake meat or medical procedures or
anything that is tied into his money
bill gates is known to have a reputation
for punishing people cutting funding
getting rid of money because his money's
in all of the medical community almost
and and punishing people for daring to
release data or information that goes
against his monetary interest it's
called the bill chill and it should
terrify everyone especially looking at
our modern day scientific community and
how easily could be manipulated by by
the millions of dollars that he puts
into it
we're living in an age of uh basically
real-life bond villains and uh james
bond is alex jones
i'm trying to think of a good a good
rhyme with fouchy because the bill gates
method is exactly the voucher method
it's when you control the purse strings
of the funding you'll get you'll you'll
get people to say what you want uh and
then the doctors that speak out or
whoever else speaks out
they'll get the this is why they're
pushing the fake me the corporate media
saying this is great this is awesome for
the environment well well that that that
that's looking like it's not the truth
it's nutritious well that's also new
data coming out so it's it's not like
meat exactly
and again it's it's about just trying to
reprogram people to to accused to go
along with eating soy and bugs and all
this other stuff that is not good for
you and people need to really understand
the influence that these people have
because when the information comes out
highlighting how these people were lying
manipulating and marketing their
products through science uh when people
call it out we get censored we get
attacked and then we get down ranked in
the algorithm demonetized and shut off
from the internet they're trying to plug
everybody into the matrix man
they can't have you handing out red
pills luke
yeah pretty much yeah it's been it's
been an uphill battle for a very long
time i mean you've been there with me uh
you took it you were the first to get
demonetized
yeah yeah one of the first channels it
was it wasn't even yellow they just took
off the money sign and i was like what
is this does anyone know what's
happening here no one knew yellow didn't
so before youtube had demonetization
right so if for those of you you go on
youtube and in in the studio you upload
a video and there will be a green dollar
sign that means you've got ads if it
turns yellow it means you're limited if
it turns red with a line through it the
ads have been removed or can be grayed
out and say not eligible
before that any of that it was just a
green dollar sign saying it hasn't been
turned on i'm sitting and talking to
luke and he's like what happened he
looks at his video and the dollar time's
gone and then has to go back in the
video and turn it on again and it comes
back because youtube didn't actually
actually have a plan for demonetization
so and then there was absolutely they
manually did it and there was options to
not even turn the money on
it was and they got rid of that option i
was like wait what's going on here i i
made public posts about this i made
videos about this i was like is this
happening to anyone else no and this was
before the major wave of them just
attacking people's livelihoods and
trying to also this is another
underhanded thing that they're doing
because they're also incentivizing
people to talk about particular issues
or have stances on particular issues
because they know it's going to give
them money they know they're going to be
able to monetize content if they say
this they know if they they counter it
they're going to lose money i just want
to point out that
from 10 years ago when they were trying
to
destroy your youtube channel because you
were you were going up to prominent
individuals and questioning them and
challenging them ben bernanke several
times you know he was he chair of the
federal reserve yep
a lot a whole bunch of them so 10 years
later your face is on a time square
billboard i know
so the way i see it is we keep we keep
pushing back we keep challenging these
things and we're going to keep winning
well the the the other thing is you know
that by the subjects that they're
targeting whatever they whatever they
tinker with the algorithm is the
you know unwelcome discussion of the day
you know that it's not what they're
telling you uh the january 6 committee
hearings i've been live streaming it in
as much as it's been tedious and
soul-crushing
uh the first one i put up
got demonetized you know as i'm five
minutes into the stream demonetized fine
i ask for remonetization it gets
manually uh approved for monetization
good i'm all happy i checked just for
the fluke of it a day later it's been
age restricted and
and
i was like guys you just approved it
yesterday but you know that this is were
you debunking
i was commentating but it got manually
approved after it got it got remonetized
after manual approval and it's like you
can't a day later after you said it was
good after manual review say it's not
good and you just know it's a subject
they want to control the narrative on
and that's their way of doing it soft
censorship they say don't talk about it
because you won't get paid for it oh by
the way you're not getting paid for it
so we're not gonna we're not gonna
promote it because we're not making
money on it and that's how they just
control the narrative through the soft
indirect and hard censorship of
demonetization yep and and and
that's what i was mentioning earlier
mentioning earlier about how
you know they'll censor 60 of the right
and only a small portion of the left
that it creates a lopsided narrative
where the left gets to say more than the
right does hoping that it skews politics
in that direction with demonetization
left-wing channels get demonetized less
than the right does many many people on
the right have been banned and booted
sometimes not even warning
restricting the access to funding
does the same thing you make sure
certain ideas can't survive but i will
tell you this they are losing
they're losing man that's why i
mentioned you know luke they tried
destroying his youtube channel and now
he's on one of the biggest billboards in
times square because we're and that's
why i wanted to do it to make that
statement to make that point because we
can yeah because they're not going to
win this one well when your free speech
is going to win is so desperate that you
have to gatekeep to protect amber hurd
you know you're in it and you're just
discrediting yourself on a constant
continuous basis uh though it won't be
long before youtube comes after lawtube
because they showed independent
information independently streaming
trials people like nick ricada people
like emily baker all that people like
legal bites that whole crowd that okay
people can come to their own independent
conclusions they don't have to rely on
the washington post interpretation of
events and it turns out the washington
post put a liar and a defamer in on
their front opinion pages for a fake
story that and to continue to make amber
heard the symbol of me too if you wanted
to destroy me too that's what you would
try to do and yet they continue to do so
and instead they're going to try to
probably go after demonetization that's
their theory their theory is oh these
people must have taken johnny depp's
side not because the facts were
overwhelming in the side but because
they got super is the taylor lorenz
story yeah yeah i mean infamous libeler
nobody alive i mean she libeled uh
arianna jacobs
influences oh a back of ways and she's
not political at all she's just somebody
that was an economic competitor to
certain key people in hollywood who were
aligned with taylor lorenz and just just
one thing david mamet had a great
expression or a great saying every fear
hides a wish robert in that fear might
be a wish come after law tube i don't
think they will
because
they might they might get sued if they
try to mess you know try to try to
we're going after 50 lawyers all at once
and there's a community there but like
they taylor lorenz washington posts uh
it was washington post right when after
elita legal bites emily d baker and and
their criticism they're making money
right hey you know what they're making
money and they're making lots of it
probably more than you because of their
merit she called them radicalized for
commenting on a pop culture civil court
case that is insane women they're two
women who took the side of johnny depp
and they're they're calling them
misogynist johnny depp who threatened
the president it's not like he's
associated with the right i mean this is
a guy that's been part of the strong
left but it's just amber heard story was
clearly fake from day one i mean it was
clear the british courts were
intimidated by the court of public
opinion that's why they issued that
ruling anybody who followed that case
knew that ruling made no sense uh in
what is the whole i mean that was a
fairfax jury that was a liberal
democratic right down the street not
that far away no it was like the idea
that this would had anything to do with
politics but it shows their gatekeeping
obsession is that you can never descent
from our viewpoint and if you do you
have to be critical i i just want to say
what little credibility taylor lorenz
may have had went out the window when
she accused youtubers of being
radicalized for commenting on pop
culture yeah look what do you
i'm sorry but like commenting on pop
culture is the most generic normal
american thing that it's like tmz it's
it's it's gossip magazines people being
like johnny depp and amber heard movie
stars let me give you my opinions and
people being like well i think this
that's radicalization because i'm sorry
if you want to talk about like white
nationalists and stuff talk about
radicalization i'm listening but when
you claim that commenting on johnny depp
was radicalizing you have been
radicalized i'm just like a female a
female practicing attorney commenting on
a on a trial is radicalized i mean it's
it's it is she she lost credibility a
long time ago but again usa today how
are they still certified taylor lorenz
how is she still employed or getting
contracts
can you can you imagine being one of
these veteran reporters at the
washington post you know you're there
for 20 years
and you're just dreaming of that day
that you can be like woodward and
bernstein and you're going to get that
big story and you know over the past 10
years past eight years it's been really
kind of oh you know it's just getting
weird and then they hire this this high
paid you know millennial who just
writes garbage conflict of interest news
and nonsense and you're like that's it
that's the talent that's the big money
yeah how could you oh you'd gotta quit
and i'd
well let me or you end up the subject
like the one reporter did to uh being
potentially uh doxed by his own fellow
workers for making a joke in the sense
of the personal attacks that just
escalated i mean what we're seeing i
mean you look at the white house
remember sternovich when he went there
and he was like look at all these are
all kids these are all 20 year olds they
have no clue about the real world oh
yeah yeah we had we had someone on the
show once um
who said that they weren't familiar with
joe biden's administration because they
were only they were like a young
teenager
and i was like oh
so you that's why you voted for him i'm
36 i remember i remember what it was
like 10 years ago i remember what the
obama administration was doing in the
middle east so when joe biden comes
around i'm like none of that
but you were 12.
so you had no idea what happened but now
you're old enough to vote that's all you
do well you're seeing some of the old
left that's coming back up uh that's you
know with jimmy dore aaron mate glenn
greenwald that's actually resurfacing in
the pope bill maher in the post-trump
era now that they're past tds who are
just discovering oh wow joe biden's
really a warmonger he's actually been a
warmonger for 30 years but they're
rediscovering this bill mark corrupt
corporate hack for 30 years and finally
he's being exposed as such we had dennis
prager on the other day and he was
saying that he's not going to uh you
know fault bill maher for you know for
being a liberal but trying and calling
things out so you know given the space i
think it's fair point bill maher has
called out a lot of the will craziness
and so as a media personality i can
respect that i just wish the guy would
read the news yeah yeah exactly he
comments on it without reading it and
that's just crazy a week after covington
happens he's still wrong about it and
i'm like and the audience is cheering
exactly let me pull up this story from
john nicosia
source stelter is down to weeks if not
days left at cnn they go on he is
everything that reminds the new owners
of the zucker era they desperately want
to get past
they continue
management is confident stelter is the
one sharing the internal pushback to
fellow media reporters while
simultaneously stirring discontent
within the ranks looks like we've got
some more here
he said at 1 49 p.m
to uh uh february 222 i'm sorry february
2nd uh 2022 two sources former cnn
zucker uh former cnn zucker's girlfriend
allison gollust will not be staying on
with the network once dust settles and
then he publishes
on february 20th she resigns so he's
basically saying he was right then
brian stelter may be on the way out at
cnn i i bring him up along with this
taylor loren story because like i
mentioned i'm just going to say it again
there is a big picture of luke owski in
the middle of times square one of the
biggest billboards how is that for
winning and pushing back on the elites
and telling them that we are taking
these spaces to see these people getting
the boot to see their credibility in the
gutter it's a it's a good day
daily wire had a story on that article
and i think your tweet response to this
was in there and i noticed mine was as
well because i got a google alert
there's a part of me i genuinely feel
bad for uh stelter
stelter
stealth
um delta i genuinely feel bad for him
to some extent but but he has
demonstrated actual malice he
demonstrated malice with that kid who
asked him the question uh recently at uh
yeah the high school kids the high
school kid he was uh i i feel terrible
he uh he came on the show for an
interview um
i won't remember his name
you know puts on a smiley face oh yeah
we really have to work better on this as
the media and then gives him the cold
shoulder when the cameras aren't running
stuff they're liars but
my analogy was that you know it it's an
actual it comes from real life
experience in our country place my
parents cottage we had most problem and
we put out a bucket of of a bucket with
some bird seed in it and to wait for the
mice to get up they got up they fell in
they didn't get back out they were all
happy until they ran out of food then
they started eating each other oh lit
literally so
this is where you're going this is like
mice in a bucket they'll they'll play
with each other when you know there's
enough food to eat and then when the
food starts going short they literally
start eating each other no honor among
scoundrels and it couldn't happen to a
better industry yeah man i gotta say i
agree
we're watching the downward spiral man
yeah independent media is gonna take
over it is taking over the stuff i see
in the background of what's happening
people from these types of organizations
coming to us wanting to go the
independent route this is
the world is changing
and a lot of these organizations don't
see it quite yet but there are some
individuals in some of these
organizations that do and they're
starting to reach out and
this is something that's going to i
think accelerate a lot in the next you
know six months to a year especially
over the next two three years yeah
independent media will take over i
definitely inevitable i definitely agree
with you because the the more they try
to suppress the truth the more they
promote the the truth uh tellers but
it's even talent at these organizations
that are starting to realize this and
they're starting to realize they're
restricted and they wanted they want to
have a show like tim's in three it's
happening
three in three years
um we're i'm gonna be it's gonna be you
know uh wednesday
it's gonna be thursday at 9 00 a.m
and i'm gonna be like hey luke that uh
four six is coming out you wanna go you
wanna go catch it over at the a local
amc and look to be like oh okay we'll
catch that thursday preview and we're
gonna show up we're gonna walk up to the
counter to get some snow caps and brian
stuff is gonna turn around and be like
would you like anything else
he'll be fine he made a lot of money the
one thing is chris probably had no idea
10 years ago when you started rumble
you for the next five years are going to
be
uh number one target because this is
you're starting something which is going
to be the platform
for the independent voices who are being
snuffed out pushed out and censored on
what had hithertube in the free speech
platforms
so
are you are you okay
i better be i better be well that's uh i
i love what i do i love this space and i
really strongly believe in it so
absolutely did you guys see that smear
piece about florida like the far right
is moving which one oh yeah
i've seen a few other
smear pieces like every week there's one
i think i just typed in brian stetler
into a brave search and one of the
articles that comes up is from the new
york post talking about how his reliable
sources first of all why would you name
a show like that when you're such a
propagandist but that's why but it's
titled reliable sources on cnn draws
lowest ratings since 2019.
so they're feeling i mean it's it's
73 000 viewers in the key demographic
that's how many views i get when i post
a video of chickens outside tim that you
had half you had 40 000 people watching
an empty studio for two and a half hours
last week i mean and and and generating
revenue while it happens i mean it's
nuts people want to support quality the
people who can't succeed on a
merit-based system yep want to suppress
that quality exactly the people at these
big these big journalist outlets
they have no merit they have no talent
and so they rely on this gigantic
foundation of a hundred-year-old
institution or or institutions so that
they can climb they can be let in the
front door take the elevator to the top
and then scream their garbage opinions
at the world for the rest of us that use
that have built up our own followings
and done the hard work over time it's
because we've said things that have been
insightful we've challenged we've been
brave or we've just done the hard work
and over a long enough period of time
that results in a following that's merit
they could never earn and they despise
us for it
well think about it you know
collectively you guys have more members
on your own subscription stuff than cnn
plus put together
with 300 million dollars of investment
that was horrifying like think about
that
i
i
i did a live stream with nate brody
another youtube lawyer of the law tube
about the jan six hearings and i'm
pulling up articles published
publications i want to get anyone in
trouble on this but relating to
previous reporting by cnn npr
about issues with machines leaving it at
that
cnn had a video from 10 years ago it had
1400 views on it and this is cnn with
they have millions 1400 views and
there's stuff now there's a reason why
they turn off comments there's a reason
why they don't let you see the thumbs up
well that was youtube but
it's the reason why youtube did that
don't question this to protect the weak
and and punish the strong
well the the saying uh goes that any
sufficiently unmoderated platform will
become right-wing but the idea is that
the right probably has a tendency
towards meritocracy because the people
who are strong enough to lead end up
doing it their view of it is
the people of twitter at twitter have
said this they need to create a health
the health of the conversation like you
were mentioning earlier
so they view themselves as stewards of
fairness
it doesn't work you can't cut off the
tall grass and
tall grass sacrifice those who do the
hard work and then prop up people who
don't and that's what they've been doing
and it doesn't work it's it's creating
all of this all these problems i i i
would flip the expression i i appreciate
the expression but i wouldn't say
anything left to its own or you know
free speech tends to turn right wing i
would just say that those who tend to
fail on their own merits
try to restrict the rules so it nothing
changes in the essence except for the
the the overton's window shifts to the
left so what was
center looks like it was right-wing but
no
freedom of speech
tends to go right-wing not so much it's
that those who don't succeed with their
speech try to suppress the speech of
those who do in i would say in the last
like three four months you know we've
seen a lot of people on the left
perceived left come to rumble
um that you wouldn't typically have
thought would have came
like activists for example susan
sarandon tweeting rumble like what that
actually happened she's she's on the
left i thought right
um so you're starting to see like this
kind of
the this free speech
thing happen
on all angles now it's not just
happening with one
defined group but many different groups
gaming whatever it may be any category
it's happening across the spectrum and
it's getting really aggressive and worse
well it's why the young turks uh you
know are now being critical of
independent left creators the i mean
they grew up as being the book as being
the bernie sanders auntie obama you know
voice of the progressive left that the
institutional media wasn't covering then
they transition into trump hatred and
then they transition into being sort of
corporate establishment media that they
themselves used to be critical of have
to rely on donations from corporate and
uh big you know billionaire sugar
daddies on the left and consequently
their their support is shrinking and
shrinking and shrinking because they're
no longer organic or authentic or
independent there's people on the left
that could build a huge uh a independent
market spectrum like tulsi gabbard like
glenn greenwald like aaron mate like max
blumenthal son of city blumenthal like
the gray zone uh if they uh continue to
do independent information that's
reliable and trustworthy even though it
comes from a left perspective the thirst
and the hunger is for independent honest
authentic information exactly yeah kyle
kalinski and crystal ball i think are
fantastic well there's there's the the
the no true scotsman thing about this is
that left wing voices who want to
succeed they move to rumble but the
second you do that you become right wing
so tulsi gabbard ghost rumble right wing
russell brand goes to rumble right wing
jimmy dore goes rumble right wing and so
jimmy dore is a socialist isn't he he's
he's the guy who spat on alex jones in
the 2016. we were there me and him were
in the room as it was happening
that's assault brother
it technically was but i mean glenn
greenwald when you call the the the gay
liberal uh who's very critical of
bolsonaro and brazil uh in the guy who
helped break probably more investigative
journalistic stories than any individual
reporter in the last decade you call him
right wing it shows that they they have
a fallback position they called joe fast
company one article saying you know
beware right-wing comedy from joe rogan
to the babylon b and it's like what okay
i'll take it i guess look it just
it becomes a circular definitional veer
away your right wing even if you're even
if you're as left as russell brand and
tulsi gabbard you veer you're right and
that's it joe rogan goes on his show and
says universal basic income which is
very very left and like he's right wing
okay dude his favorite candidate was
between bernie sanders and tulsi gabbard
i mean he's been consistently on the
left so the but i think it's just
self-discrediting like like when you get
to the point where you're calling johnny
depp supporters right wing you have lost
the narrative and you've lost
institutional conditions you are if you
when you're at the point where
commenting on a johnny depp civil case
means you're radicalized you've lost to
the plot and that's that's the corporate
press at this point there were people on
our respective communities robert barnes
and i they didn't they didn't care for
johnny depp because he because of his
anti-trump statements you know and call
for violence statements um
but when it comes to these types of
things that people who are independent
thinkers can see beyond their own biases
and just come to the conclusions based
on the facts and yeah just anyone who
agrees with johnny depp right-wing
misogynist even if they happen to be
left-wing women
let that let's let's talk about rumble
we have this from corp.removal.com
rumble propose proposes an open source
content moderation policy and process to
improve transparency and put craters
first so
for those that might not be familiar
maybe uh you're new to politics i'm
assuming it's probably a small
percentage of people most will probably
know this stuff tim one thing this is
exclusive to you released on independent
media
not through the typical channels just to
add to the previous stuff right on
so obviously for those you know youtube
youtube has been big but youtube has
banned people without warning youtube
has censored information they don't like
and they've done very shady things if we
want to have open and honest
conversations we need to be able to be
on platforms that have that are healthy
and robust
so with rumble which is
it's how would you describe it how are
you a video hosting service
the way to describe rumble we're
we're a platform that's uh with two
different things both video and cloud
now so we're going to be pushing cloud a
lot in 2023 but we're we're a video
platform an open and free video platform
that's going to protect the free and
open internet as much as possible truth
social is uh that uses rumble
infrastructure it does yeah their entire
actually when they opened up the
floodgates when you're able to come on
it was because they moved over to the
rumble cloud and timcast.com uses
rumble's infrastructure for our video
player on the members only section of
the of the show which is monday through
thursday at 11 pm sign up become a
member but all of the hosting the entire
website is built on your guys
infrastructure because there's got to be
we have to build something that is alter
an alternative to silicon valley's
monopoly on the space and it has to be
resilient to censorship it has to be
competitive i think you guys are so
let's talk about what this what this
move was trying to make the rules more
fair better and this helps you compete
but it's also better for the people yeah
so
one this was completely inspired by your
show we you know we took a lot of flack
with our terms and conditions you put it
up there six months ago and i was like
[ __ ] you know this thing hasn't changed
for a long time and it's you know we we
went through a time period of eight
years
um when i came on in january where you
know things changed a lot in the way
we've kind of built our track record
over the last eight years is based on
terms and conditions where we didn't
move the goal posts and we kept really
really sturdy we didn't change the
definitions of certain things
and our track record proved to be really
good we you know we we don't ban for
things that are that don't make sense
and we're not doing what youtube's doing
but
the term said we could ban you any time
we want for anything we want we however
we want
we had this conversation a lot of the
rules were very similar it was
yeah with with the exception of all like
the misinformation stuff that youtube
so uh viva and barnes you guys what you
came up with a plan or something or what
happened so it's the same plan that i
talked about with twitter you know five
years ago and with twitter it talked
about being amenable too and then backed
out of the last minute which is you can
create a space that protects a free and
open internet without being bombarded by
trolls and haters and harassers and
stalkers and doctors and defamers you
can have something that is a free and
open space free both from censors and
free from stalkers and the rules are
right there the rules are there in
american law the rules are there in jury
instructions the rules are there already
laid out you're not supposed to have
discriminatory misuse or abuse of a
platform because of section 230 there
hasn't been a lot of u.s litigation but
there are ways in which you can create
rules that are a desirable community
that maximizes freedom of speech like
right now you can go to rumble and if
you want to look get independent free
information like we did an interview
with dinesh d'souza in 2000 mules we
could only do it on rumble but you can
create a space that is free for those
kind of discussions that you can have
heterodox opinions that you can have
heretical opinions and be completely
free to share those with your community
and at the same time have rules that are
not only consistent with that but also
open and transparent the other aspect of
this was have an appeals process that
matters what frustrates a lot of people
is that they get suddenly banned without
notice without knowledge without means
of a meaningful appeal happen to eric
hunley uh
unstructured podcast and all he does is
just interview interesting and uh
interesting people so the goal was let's
create an appeal process that works and
it's manageable and that's where viva
helped create a lot of those because
he's been through that process knows
other people that's been through that
process also make it participatory but
we mean we've had american democracy for
about 300 years and the goal is to
we've learned that an open transparent
participatory process produces the best
result and best outcomes it's telling
about the free market of ideas it's
about letting the ordinary person
participate where we're talking about
earlier that's who often gets targeted
for suspension and banning on social
media it's the ordinary person that's
why these rules are just proposed rules
people can actually look at these rules
and say we see a problem here we see we
think this could be improved there's a
there's actually an email set up that
they can actually email in their ideas
their suggestions their comments make
this process as best as possible and
ultimately have a community and content
creator jury that will help adjudicate
these processes so the goal is let's
create something that will work for the
entire big tech universe let's create
the model chris has been willing to open
source these rules so anybody can borrow
them anybody can copy them anybody can
imitate them this is about making the
free and open internet free and open
again the the jury system i think is
interesting mine's implemented something
similar minds.com mind yes it's so hard
to say because it sounds like you're
saying it sounds like you're seeing
minds
they had a system where if someone posts
something
that is a violation of the rules they
have moderators if you post something
that's like illegal content like you
know child abuse and stuff it gets nuked
if you post something
it could and it's like maybe that's
violence or whatever it gets sent to a
jury of users
and then they're asked to vote on it and
then i'm not exactly sure how it works
but then they can vote yeah this breaks
the rules if it does break the rules all
that happens is they put a filter on it
that says not safe for work
anything that would instantly have to be
removed for like law breaking and stuff
is removed no matter what because
that's just law breaking content but as
for the community guidelines the worst
that can happen i believe is they just
put a filter on it where it blurs the
image and then you have to choose to see
it so you don't even get banned for
posting you know hateful stuff or
anything like that yeah you run into the
issue about people posting their own
criminality or or things along those
lines but so full disclosure one thing
robert and i have been working with
rumble for these terms for a little
while but
haven't we don't like rumble because
we're working with them we're working
with them because we like them and i
knew rumble since 2014 when i was just
posting cat videos type things and they
were just a video hosting platform and
licensing agency
um
what they're doing now is is amazing and
important because people are getting
shafted left right and center on youtube
they're getting sauce censored into
discussing only the things that youtube
will allow them to we've gotta when we
have certain controversial uh figures on
and those are by the way doctors uh i
had to do one interview specifically on
rumble with dr chris francis christian
because youtube i knew it was going to
happen on youtube um
but other people say like well i want
free speech on the internet that means
running around and seeing you know
racial expedition whatever and
that's not what freedom of speech in the
meaningful sense on the internet means
what it means is that you have objective
clear-cut rules that are not going to be
weaponized for political and
narrative-driven purposes so you know
hashtag learn to code is not going to be
tolerable when the left says it but when
the right says it it's a call to
violence banning right and so that's
what you have to navigate with with the
internet i think we've done it but yeah
we've created the same rules that for
public squares that exist all across
america they have rules right you can't
go to a local public square and do
pornography do obscenity uh dude you
know try to attack somebody you can't do
any of that so we just took those cities
these days to be honest i wouldn't be
surprised yes unfortunately yes you've
been to san francisco yeah
well hey there you get it at little kids
reading you know book story time you
know surprise surprise but the uh the
goal is to take what those historic
rules have been and apply them to the
digital public square and make it as
transparent and open as part of the
process but people can continue to
partake and participate in this if they
think there's improvements we can make
that rumble can make they're invited to
do so this is the beginning of a
participatory process to return the
internet to its roots of being open and
free
i dig it no it's great and and the the
sort of call it board review or
community review it works when the when
the community doesn't get radicalized
when it doesn't get filtered down
through its own soft censorship and so
you know people who love the community
want to preserve it uh they're going to
preserve it and they're going to
preserve it so that they can all speak
freely this sounds good but but how does
it work how the how are you going to
implement it and put it into action
who's going to be making the calls about
what is allowed and what is not so it's
a three-fold process so one is the
actual rules themselves to make them
open transparent easily accessible
that's what's being posted i believe now
already yeah if you scroll up on the
because if you break a youtube rule
youtube uh doesn't really tell you which
rule you broke or why or what you could
do for any possible redemption
and that goes to the second part of the
process so we helped first design the
rules we're there's also going to be
posting guidelines of how we're
interpreting and applying these rules
just using jury instructions uh using
things that ordinary jurors use every
day in terms of the rules but the rules
are really simple straightforward
accessible they use uh identified legal
terms throughout the united states for
which we have uh have 200 years plus of
history now the second part of the
process was what you're talking about
how does it get adjudicated how do you
get notified of it who decides what role
do you have in responding to it uh what
do you know who the uh the the the jury
pool is consistent of is that a publicly
disclosed list that's what viva took
lead on
yeah
bottom line you have your clear-cut
rules yeah
there's automated stuff for copyright
trademark uh if
other than that if a community member a
user flags something there's going to be
a first review by rumble and if they
determine it's okay
it'll it'll continue there might there
will be flagging for people who to avoid
brigading to to avoid what i suspect
happens a lot on youtube people don't
like your stuff so they just go randomly
and with impunity flag it if people fly
too many things uh that are deemed to be
unfair flagging they'll suffer the
consequences so people it'll
it'll create a sense of responsibility
will they be down ranked in the
algorithm or how will their account just
be punished for abusing the system
ultimately suspended in bard if they
continue if they just if they just
continuously flag and wrongly flag
content that rumble and or the community
determines is not flag worthy they'll
get strikes to the point where they get
suspended or permanently banned although
even chris has a big heart there will be
no permanent bands except for egregious
stuff it'll be a year ban if you violate
you know over and over and over again to
the point where you break the rules
which are going to be clear if you don't
like them
that's going to be the other bottom line
is the rules are there it's not a
lawless society if you don't like the
rules
that'll be your decision but one thing
you can rely on is that they're not
going to be politically weaponized to go
after one side of the ideological
spectrum uh and immunize the other and
you'll be given specific notice on which
rule is being alleged to be violated
you'll give an opportunity to respond an
opportunity to respond to rumble after
that if you don't like it you can appeal
it to the community board the community
board is going to be fully publicly
disclosed it will be content creators
and members that are invested in the id
of rumble as a free speech platform they
will make a review and you have an
opportunity to uh oppose them and even
then if it's a first offense that only
leads to the content being taken
what about sentencing
after you're convicted of breaking the
rules
and then there's a structured process
you have to violate it i think four
times within six months before you face
any kind of
deletion of a channel and even then it's
only for a year time period so four
strikes because you were talking about
strike systems
there's two there's two different
processes so one that we're really
changing here that i really like is the
is the copyright thing we're going to
give everybody an opportunity to take
down the video if there's a copyright or
challenge it before it's taken down
before an actual strike is applied to
the channel and like on youtube you can
get like 100
three or four strikes and your channel
is gone so we're gonna give the creator
an opportunity to appeal it right away
without applying any strikes give them a
12 to 24 hour period
to figure that out um that's on the
copyright side on the
on the policy takedown side if you look
at the policies they're all related to
like unlawful conduct but
let's say you do a bunch of things that
are that are wrong if it's egregious
then obviously you're not there's going
to be no forgiveness but if they're
if there's
nuance to something then you're going to
be able to come back within a year what
does no forgiveness mean permanent man
yeah well
when we first went through it it was uh
it was permanent bands for people that
break the rules four times within a
within uh a six-month period but then i
said i was talking to to both of you and
you know i really felt like there has to
be a way in a path to forgiveness
because
everyone gets forgiven and like either
well even murderers
you can get 25 years if they're killing
someone and still get let back out and
join them that only that is only based
on whether or not you believe in reform
for the ones you want to reform but
other ones it's immediately permanent
banning and and you know being kicked
out of society right i suppose there
would be a life sentence you know what i
mean and i think posting child abuse
photos
is should be like
a certain like yeah and that's what
we're and that's what we've come to
right so like but we're like i said
these are these are just proposed we we
don't want to make these changes to the
community until we feel the community is
fully on board with it and this is our
first step towards going towards that um
because it is moving it's the first time
we're going to move the goalposts but i
think we're going to move the goalposts
in the opposite direction and really
they're trying to take their rules and
comply with what they've been doing for
the last eight years yeah
it goes very in line with our track
record the big question i hear from a
lot of people is
ui update update when huh yes that well
it's it's on the ios app now
so you can see the new ui on the ios app
um and the the website the website that
that'll be coming in the coming months
cool
so it's looking good i guess
it sounds like um something that we used
to have in the in the u.s legal system
called the due process
exactly we don't really have that
anymore we have a lot of freedom of
expression freedom of speech freedom of
press due process of law jury trial
rights all these ideas we've borrowed
from to incorporate in the big tech
space to restore the public square to
the internet so these are the proposed
rules who's going to decide that these
rules and content moderation is going to
be moving forward and are you guys
specifically saying you can't say this
this political ideology is not allowed
this is okay this is not is is this the
process so what we have posted up there
is pretty much the what what we're
proposing right now um and we're
gathering feedback you can email us
there's an email posted there that where
you can
send us feedback and what you like and
what you don't like so we can take that
back but one of the things i really want
to do is
you know i i've founded rumble i i've
run rumble but i'm not i'm not a i'm not
a creator that focuses on law i'm not i
don't have a law degree like who am i to
to to really put this together that and
the best thing i could think of is
coming to creators that have law degrees
and understand this they understand free
free speech better than anyone else to
suggest something is there a political
ideology that's off limits like if like
a group signed up you'd be like
no i mean it's designed if you're making
illicit content so like the clan and the
antifa tends to make
illegal content but there's no ban on
the clan there's no ban on antifa
there's no ban on anybody i mean like
one of i still think the best
measurement for whether a platform is
consistent about freedom of speech is is
alex jones on that platform alex jones
has had zero problems on rumble that
that's shown there and even when senator
scott from florida came after him
because they allowed rt to be on rumble
rumble didn't change their position so
even when the united states senator from
the state that rumble is partially
located in came after him they they
stayed with it so i was only willing to
invest my time if chris was sincere and
chris was clearly sincere because i've
been uh passionate about this for more
than half a decade i gotta say i'm i
think sincerity is great but the reality
is this is the market opportunity if
you're trying to grow a business this is
how you do it well yeah you imagine uh
take youtube as a specific example where
they have as a rule for content
we we will deem misinformation remove
strike and penalize channels for
suggesting anything that runs a foul of
what the who is saying right now
and bear in mind that the who the world
health organization has that depending
on the year said both a and not a or
both a and b a and b and so
you don't even know what the rule is
going to be for the for the for on the
going forward basis let me tell you i
had a meeting with google not that long
ago and i said
i advise
all young people to start on rumble
because while the audience size
certainly is much smaller your
opportunity for growth is much larger
you're more likely to find it not you're
going to find an audience faster
and you're less likely to have your
business destroyed
due to arbitrary rules and i said i
gotta be honest with you i don't know
what the rules are and i read them every
day it's remarkable because i have seen
people get banned for one thing and not
something else i have seen a prominent
left-wing podcaster call for an act of
terror and he got a strike
is that it
i know another guy who had his entire
channel deleted because he did black
comedy that's it he broke no rules he
was monetized
and they and they just delete his
channel outright with no warning with no
strikes purge
this was my own like i've been on
youtube before i was really focusing on
rumble but since 20 whatever 14
this was my initial experience with what
i call youtube chicanery it was the alex
jones deposition video all i did as a
lawyer total cringe stood on the roof of
my house with sunglasses breaking down
an alex jones deposition i didn't know
that aj was persona non grata on youtube
i do it the video gets like close to a
quarter of a million views then they
pull it or they demonetize it then they
pull it and then i notice i got a term
of community guidelines violation for
hate speech so the video's gone all
that's left is when you click on it
community guidelines violation for hate
speech and
i it was and then then it comes back on
two weeks later and it gets re-monetized
senator rand paul was speaking on the
senate floor
c-span published the video and youtube
took it down
youtube you are psychopaths
and then let's also be honest here if
there's a big brand a big business or
the corporate media they get the front
door at youtube they get walked right in
they get pushed in the algorithm the
trending videos that's the videos that
that of course are connected to the
biggest businesses that are connected to
their google advertisement uh businesses
and revenue so so there's already a
clear bias if you're an independent
media creator and i wanted to bring this
up with you guys when you're on youtube
there's no way the algo
algorithm is going to be playing you any
favors unless you have big money that's
why rumble is such a such a good
alternative as well as the other
alternatives out there but but who
decides what's going to be in the
algorithm last time we talked about let
people see what they want to see if
they're subscribed to something let them
see it um
how is the algorithm going to be shaped
to what rumble's going to be showing
people how you know how will independent
creators fare in that kind of ranking
system so the way it is right now is
just chronological so there
as far as an algorithm goes it's
chronological by time um i think the
important thing to do and i think ian
mentioned this last time is have have
these algorithms open sourced yeah um if
we do deploy an algorithm right now
because it's chronological there's
really nothing to open source in time
isn't there a challenge though that if
they know how the algorithm works
they'll game it
there there is um so like the way you
can game a chronological algorithm is
just keep putting content out constantly
and flooding the feed so like that's
that's one way to do it but like
isn't that on the cur is it on the
viewer if they're if you're flooding the
feed don't follow them so you cut back
on who you follow this is how this is
how we were running social media 10 15
years ago um but we all went towards
these engagement-based algorithms that
amplify content based on engagement and
that changed everything and changed the
games they figured out they can skew
things they figured out they could do
things um i think if you keep it
chronological it's helpful and but that
doesn't solve the problem for
for discovery
so in order to have discovery of
creating independent creators you're
going to need to provide some kind of
algorithm and some kind of some kind of
mechanism
and what we want to do is have that
discovery like
kind of like in a tick-tock format where
you can kind of go through and scroll
through scroll through content um and
open source that algorithm where that
algorithm will be based basically on you
know how much you like a video how much
you dislike a video and whether or not
you have a preference for that video so
we're working on something like that
right now because discovery is super
important um to help find craters and we
should have something hopefully by the
end of the year that's it's already
launched right now but it doesn't have
an algorithm in it the algorithm is very
basic it's based on likes and the ratio
of likes that's it
and then the other way is through search
is just making sure your search is uh
we would like to open source that as
well in making sure that you when you
find something you understand how you
place the search your place in the
search base right now based on time the
excel the the velocity of views and
the the
the the context of the video so the
characters the titles the descriptions
it's very simplistic right now and if it
does become something more complicated
then open sourcing that is i think
critical
but the discovery portion is the part
that we all want to solve for because
once you nail that and you give
viewership to small creators then you
really have something special what what
about your uh rumbles api is it going to
are there going to be an option for
people to uh i don't know
develop on top of the software embedding
it incorporating it so we already have
that so rumble player which is you know
going to be part of this rumble cloud
business that we're building um
is has open apis that you can use to
search find and embed into other
platforms
cool
sounds like everything's there huh yeah
not yet not yet still lots of work
there's a lot of work so we're done we
won
i never understood what algorithm is
more relevant than like and uh subscribe
retention rate no people watching a
video and liking it i can see from a
monetary perspective engagement even if
it's negative
youtube had the problem where every
video started with the guy screaming
smash the like button for 30 seconds and
they turned it into a game and then all
of a sudden all the top videos were just
videos of people saying smash the like
button but that'll that'll self-correct
when people start downvoting that crap
because it's no longer fun to watch
people wouldn't even click it
so there were there were people like
they're literally just videos where a
guy for a minute it's like smash the
like button the camera's like zooming in
and out and it would get 500 000 likes
and people who don't like it just don't
click it the issue it dominates the
issue with that as well is like it will
self-correct from what we're seeing in
the data but the problem with it is is
that you know you're going to have a
platform that has a genre of videos that
that everyone likes and then a new
person comes on and it's a completely
different genre they're looking for and
how do you figure that out
i will say one thing the fact that
youtube i've said it before robert will
pontificate on this one day when youtube
takes down
uh videos from doctors on the basis of
medical misinformation i consider that i
consider that to be practicing medicine
without a license that youtube is doing
arguably unlawful in my humble opinion
absolutely
i mean for me coming from a political
space the rand paul video removal was
just
mind-boggling and they're giving out
wrong medical advice that is leading
people to be hurt their assault on on
one particular medicine and labeling it
an animal medicine
has hurt a tremendous amount of human
beings who rely on that medicine for
other things remember when uh with the
roe v wade leak
vice put out an article about how you
can take animal medication and use it to
induce abortion yeah and then someone
created a meme let me see if i posted it
i can maybe it's on my instagram because
i thought people might not be uh
appreciating the story that the same uh
agency which said you're not a horse
yada yada
at some point later on they're talking
about
what's the word not even homeopathic
alternative remedies um
it's it's bizarro upside down to induce
abortion abortion through uh horse
medicine
so yeah that's that's the level where
we're at and they're promoted in the
algorithm they're shown to everyone you
search a topic they talked about it
they're going to be shown to everyone in
the general public yeah it's it's called
horse pill theory
and uh so it's from the political
compass on instagram and like horseshoe
theory the left it shows uh
the the motherboard article talking
about taking horse a veterinary medicine
to induce abortion and then it goes to
the right and it's it's uh the horse
paste and in the middle it's bojack
horseman i just thought it was a
brilliant meme
it's like this is what you get in the
modern era i guess but they didn't ban
motherboard for recommending people eat
horse medicine please don't eat horse
medicine yeah
did i wonder if the fda did they put out
a warning on that i mean the fda is
being sued because of their tweet about
uh ivermectin so the uh deservedly so
but i mean when you have people like dr
peter mccullough you're talking about
some of the most well-respected medical
doctors in the world that are now being
censored like we're going to do an
interview with them we're going to have
to do it on rumble we cannot do it on
youtube no we're not we're going to
gleefully do it on rumble so that i can
actually ask the questions i want to ask
same thing with doctor
christian we talked about this with the
twitter story that
these twitter employees are listening to
elon musk talk and they're oblivious to
the fact that he's there because of them
because of their political bias because
of their incessant need to silence
people they don't like they have created
republican elon musk
youtube is doing the exact same thing
they are they're they're taking people
there may be someone who says like like
uh you vivo you're like i'm gonna do a
video on alex jones in his in his
deposition they ban you imagine a new
creator who's not political and they say
oh i'm in law school i really want to
talk about this they get banned they go
guess i go to rumble
now what are they what are they doing at
rumble they're seeing nothing but all
these big prominent political creators
who have been censored everything
youtube was trying to silence now front
and center for those people to see they
are pushing people into the information
they claim they want to suppress it's
remarkable how insane they are well
they've done that to alex jones the all
the efforts to de-platform him have just
led more people to be curious about what
is he saying that everybody's so scared
of him and has led to more people going
to infowars more people uh going in for
store more people being engaged than
almost ever before their efforts to sign
in the irony is i mean alex was
seriously considering about retirement
after 2016. he'd achieved extraordinary
number of things over a quarter century
and then he decided to sign wage law for
law fair against him and decide to try
to take him de-platform him and he's the
kind of guy who doesn't go gently into
that good night you know and so he is
here today louder and stronger than ever
before because of their efforts to
destroy him and not just that i will say
having spent some time on the interwebs
a lot of people are now realizing that
alex jones was right more often than usa
today and when he says things
hyperbolically
he still
i don't want to throw my wife under the
bus but when uh one of the stories the
conspiracy one of the theories
uh was that 5g towers are going to mind
control you and i was like oh that's
that's garb when when you i when you
understand that by that term it just
means interfere with sleep patterns you
know it could interfere with uh a form
of of your cognitive abilities it's not
control in a sense but when you realize
that he's hyperbolic but well relatively
accurate on some things um he he he
would often take the story and then just
take this little dot and stretch it out
so
he would dramatize in order to get
attention in the rest but people pay but
people would ignore the underlying i
mean turned out they were trying to turn
some of the frogs gay you know i mean i
mean it's that kind of well that was
that so so that's that i love this story
because
the frog's gay thing was was alex
talking about atrazine i believe was a
pesticide right was it a bastard and
they said that it was interfering with
the endocrine systems of frogs all that
meant was the frogs were becoming
deformed or male formed and then alex in
his ranch it says they're turning the
freaking frogs gay and people people
literally believe that he was he was
being literal when he said that it just
no he was just doing an entertaining
rant it's much like trump that the uh
his audience doesn't take him literally
they understand the proverbial reference
to it but his deeper truth that you
can't trust institutional people in
power the people who seek power like
michael malice's theory are
disproportionately going to be dangerous
people and we have to be constantly on
the alert for him but i mean it turned
out everything he warned about you know
that they're going to use a pandemic to
help lock down and strip us of our civil
liberties well we've experienced that
that uh unique things might happen with
elections we've experienced that that
the mass censorship was coming through
big tech control we've experienced that
i think there was also something about
uh medical microchipping and
a youtube moderator is watching this
video is like oh i'm gonna ban this
video right now can i do it can i do it
now can i do it now barnes keep going
keep going well
it's just illegal
you know that's the beauty of reporting
information lawsuits going back to rand
paul this is public sourced information
so if you are saying something in
congress if something is said in court
it cannot be the subject of a libel
lawsuit or anything else if you're
fairly and accurately reporting what was
in there and so there's all this
information and yet now we can't even
talk about things that are happening in
congress or happening in courts on
youtube that's a level of insanity
when the rand paul thing happened
i had posted a video it got taken down
and the weird thing about it is
the video was still there someone
messaged me and like hey your video's
gone tim and i go into my studio on
youtube and i look and i'm like it's
right there
and then i hover the mouse over it and
the mouse doesn't change you know like
when you hover over a link it turns into
the finger pointing it didn't change i
couldn't click on anything it was like
an image and i was like what and then i
found the yorkshire tweeted or something
and i video had been removed and i was
like they tried making me think that it
was still there something like that
happened it was weird and there's a lot
of dirty tricks that we don't even know
a lot of things be happening behind the
scenes that we're not even privy to that
that they're implementing right now that
we don't even know about there's medical
doctors there's medical studies that are
being censored and banned on big tech
social media platforms that's when you
know they jump jump the shark we're
gonna change all that my friends and i
think we're winning that's why i keep
pointing out that luke's on a billboard
in times square so is ian so is michael
malus because i just i was just like we
got to put people up on this to give a
big middle finger to the establishment
but let's go to super chats and talk to
you guys if you have not already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and become a
member at timcast.com because we're
gonna have a members only exclusive
episode coming up at about 11 p.m on the
website and uh share the show with your
friends if you really like it let's see
what we got here
john shaw says why not genetically
engineer dog-sized ants chip their
brains and use them to build
infrastructure like bridges canals and
underground underground highways maybe
i'm crazy that is a particularly crazy
super chat thank you very much that
that was okay
they're turning the ants into
construction machines they're turning
the ants and dogs
they're stealing your dogs and building
bridges underground
all right jason lindholm says damn viva
that hair
yes it has gotten very long the freedom
fro will continue will continue to grow
the freedom fro will continue to be my
wife said it would stop she said it
would stop growing at one point in time
and i said that sounds like a bet
conspiracy theory
jmac says buy coffee brand coffee so the
quartering has to shave his beard he
actually did he did shave his beard this
evening uh rakita he said groomed him
that was what they were doing like a
joint stream so we shaved it live on
stream i was like
down downtown he looks so weird
he looks really effing weird
yeah i don't want to say what he's like
shut up
no insults
all right what do we got
dano says hey tim and crew love the show
and all you do with the ceo of rumbleon
i would like to ask why this show isn't
streamed live on rumble also rumble
experience is better than youtube it's
an interesting question i suppose we
don't have a a real answer as of right
now but uh stay tuned it's all i can
really say
dennis uh gregerson says heck yeah viva
and barnes love your shows on rumble
viva i watched every trucker rally live
stream you are the best viva are you
going uh to do that reporter
[Laughter]
that was definitely a suit i was going
to ask which which reporter
i'm a married man but uh
i'm getting i'm getting a quote right
now i nobody should jump into litigation
even if they're convinced they are right
but at some point enough is enough even
in their correction of the story they
then referred to the video that was
allegedly removed from youtube as a
covid video to persist in their uh
what's the world we'll be we'll be
making uh a statement as well no they're
like they're sure to persist in their
smear against rumble they have to
pretend that the video that i had
removed from youtube but wasn't removed
from rumble was coveted it was the alex
jones deposition which shows you how
idiotic things are on youtube
all right mm126 is obviously elon is a
watcher of the show nothing is
coincidental
i guess he better get on here he posted
a meme of me he did yeah did you see
that one no which is which it was the
meme of me talking to a jag guy at
twitter going in a circle yeah that was
a great meeting he tweeted at lydia and
then i immediately tweeted at him and i
said he should come on irl and discuss
this he's sitting back and he's like i'm
not going on your show i understand he
probably just likes to watch i get it
does he know that there's uh pappy's in
the back i mean yeah elon we got he
doesn't drink does he oh no that's what
depends i mean on the day or tell him
it's apple juice yeah
if you don't know he he drinks he's got
his freaking white claw that one
she drinks white clothing we can smoke
and talk about the synchronicity i got a
feeling um
you know being the richest guy on the
planet he's not too concerned about the
fancy whiskey that we have
like oh you have peppy i have 300
bottles in my backyard oh yeah
i bowl i play ball bowling with him then
you have to get him something that he's
never had before or can't get because of
where he is uh my brother-in-law makes a
nice gin and uh well he doesn't seem
like he doesn't seem like a big money
guy right i will have my mom bake her
secret recipe chocolate chip cookies oh
yeah you make that berry juice we have
yeah
wine berry wine
so uh you know we got wine berries out
here
they're
they're chinese raspberries and they
grow all over the you know appalachia
papa is the october fruit yes hillbilly
banana yeah there you go so we'll make
some hillbilly food for elon when he
comes
it's a plan
all right
what do we
got ultra maga marty smith van says i'm
aviva barnes locals member and tim cast
member thank you very much question for
chris can we have a rewind feature for
rumble lives it's my biggest complaint
and for robert can you pitch to tim cass
to have rich barris on please he's the
best
yes um we actually launched our live
streaming with that feature it was just
a little buggy um we're going back to
fixing that and should have that shortly
and you know what else you should do
speaking of rewind what youtube used to
do at the end of the year to celebrate
creators was the youtube rewind have the
rumble rewind
that's what they did to celebrate it it
was beautiful and when youtube stopped
it for one year i forget what the reason
was we said
i'll tell you the reason
it was because if they actually went
after what was popular on the platform
they would have been making hate speech
or offending the corporate press so they
started it was really funny like one of
the last youtube rewinds they did had a
bunch of creators who hadn't made videos
in like years yeah and people were
pointing out like that person didn't
make a video all year and you put them
in your thing and they're like but
they're a youtube celebrity it's like
dude this they didn't like they had will
smith on the platform like yeah
that's the most embarrassing craziest
thing they should do a rewind with will
smith this year
yeah they should
just open it with it no he's slapping
the clips back
oh that's a good idea everyone on
youtube
let's do a rumble satirical funny
version of a youtube corporate
rewind and make fun of them let's put it
on rumble let's do it
and then will smith is going to be in
there
[Laughter]
all right let's try and grab some super
chats
what do we got
camel of the mojave says if it's a
mainstream platform it's probably
already shoulder deep and being uh
shoulder deep and being puppet puppeted
around by alphabet people or having
their finances threatened
but who does that refer to
i think that's the general concern about
any platform and i think it's the
concern about rumble as they say it's
our it's so big it's already controlled
opposition or whatever
um
look if i ever felt that way i would not
be here now it's rumble is
walking the walk and chris is talking
the talk and and uh taking the flack for
it people were saying about donald trump
before he got elected that he was
controlled opposition that he was
friends with the clintons and then look
what happened when well i was not
friends with anybody i didn't know a
single person two years ago
i come from a little town outside of
toronto it sounds sketchy
which town
brampton brampton okay yeah
so outside of toronto i didn't know a
single political person my whole life
and i think it's people who believe that
the system has so much control that even
if they see something successful they
assume that too must be part of some
secret control and that that's not the
case you can fight back and win i like
to say that the greatest trick the devil
ever pulled was convincing people he did
not exist the greatest trick the system
ever pulled is convincing people they
cannot resist the reality is that's the
key that's a good one i like that
brennan the american says thanks for all
you do i'm a 27 year old who has a
garden food storage and now chickens my
wife and i feel slightly more ready for
the storm to come
you know the former ceo of home depot
came out today and said with the fed uh
hiking the rates
you better stock up on some cat you
better get some cash reserves and you
better get some non-perishables because
it is going to get bad yep and seeing
that and seeing reports of the constant
you know uh stories about food shortages
due to ukraine fertilizer and all that
stuff plus the supply chain disruption i
mean my assumption is hope you're ready
for august and september it's gonna get
but but then and then you see you see
biden putting out these tweets it's the
strongest economy like lie after lie
after lie and it's one thing for the lie
to be there the response is in the
comment section you talk about an
ideological silo of absolute political
ignorance everyone's like oh yeah
greatest economic recovery ever it's um
and then you get this distraction of the
january 6th hearing where it it's it's a
derangement
it's derangement oh this was also
predictable i mean jacob drazen who's uh
actually nearby put out the report six
months ago that this was going to happen
if we went into ukraine that there was
going to be a fertilizer and food crisis
credit to him credit to the people at
the duran who cover him you can find him
on uh youtube and richard barris going
back to the chat people's pundit was
talking about this three months ago so
yeah bears was great all these guys
independent information you would have
got you would have known this ahead of
time it's only the biden administration
that appeared
ukraine is known as the bread basket of
europe and i've been talking about that
for years
you know the history of the flag the
reason of flag yellow and blue it's the
it's the fields of wheat and the sky
that's the that's the it's in their flag
at the end of the world i thought it was
because they were big fans of west
virginia
i bought uh uh i've got
some vans for skating and they're blue
and yellow and i've had people be like
oh is that like ukraine and other people
be like oh west virginia yeah and the
funny thing is we i have an avatar on
the channel which is a tie-dye
multi-colored avatar and then people who
are new to the channel think it's for
for pride month
oh are you guys celebrating maga month
what is mega month mega month it's july
everybody every corporation has to
change their icon to an american flag
and then we we grill burgers on the
weekends can i i guess
the trump supporters told me that i was
being a [ __ ] and that we have to grill
every day so okay
okay i can tell you one thing we're not
celebrating a month in canada we're
we're hopefully at the very least just
trying to celebrate like but yeah going
outside oh yeah
yeah having some fresh air the absence
of curfew is yes freedom yeah you
canadians my goodness yeah can i show
everybody how i'm celebrating yeah with
russian candy with the russians high
fructose corn syrup candy yes so
vegetable oils shut up luke
liz so i brought in a an industrial
sized bag of patriotic sour patch kids
from mega month that's how i'm doing it
that's going to fit into a lot of jokes
in canada it's like nothing can be more
american than a bag of red white and
blue gummy bears right yeah high
fructose corn vegetable oil you might i
i i everyone loves them but my goodness
i would be um unconscious in a diabetic
shot yeah they're for the whole office
and not just mine
tim is reading super chats i am the
clueless computer i am that's right we
call them what do we got here
chris pa says i think canada wants to be
like norway where it's illegal to defend
yourself if you hurt someone in
self-defense you will be punished the
same as if you initiated the attack
i'm not sure about the uh second part of
that but one thing i can definitively
tell you you cannot own anything that is
to be used specifically for self-defense
you're not allowed owning a firearm if
the purpose of that is for self-defense
unless you get a specific license walk
around with a baseball bat no glove in a
ball and use it for self-defense you'll
probably get charged
what if you have a a sporting rifle of
some sort maybe you got a rifle for for
sport shooting and someone breaks in
your house and you defend yourself with
it so my understanding is that it will
be bona fide self-defense but you
probably will face other unrelated gun
charges it's it'll be like in new york
city people are charged like that
they'll get like fine you're off on on
murder but it'll be reckless discharge
of a firearm or pointing it at a human
it'll be like what happened with the
lady in
sweden or switzerland i think it was
sweden who used either pepper spray or a
taser to fend off an actual physical
assaulter
she got fined for unlawful possession of
a taser i think it was a taser
it's it's but leave it to justin trudeau
to revive a debate that had hitherto
been relatively quiet when he comes out
a week ago and says in canada we have a
different culture you can't own a gun
for self-defense i was like excuse me
vive he doesn't talk like that
he talks like a cult leader in canada we
have a different culture like a weird
people can't have a gun
first i hear him talking i'm like ah we
have a charter of rights that says you
have the right to life liberty and
security of the person but you cannot
guarantee for yourself your right to
life liberty or the security of the
person people are going to start asking
questions if a man breaks into your home
just get on your knees and beg him not
to harm him he's got a lot more us
but he talks like that like what is what
are you doing the and the creepiest
thing is when he starts talking to your
kids
children you've been very good it's time
for you to go i won't say i want to get
you in trouble on youtube
all right all right all right let's grab
some more
uh
andres t berzin says barnes please tell
the group while you got suspended from
twitter
oh i mean it's still not clear why i
guess i spend it from twitter so the i
didn't get officially suspended from
twitter my account just disappeared for
about like a week and then they
reinstate enough people created enough
that they accidentally well i got hacked
i got hacked and doc's wants no
reference to that the uh uh and the uh
and then the second one was uh just they
just removed my account for a period of
time then said it was a mistake
weird that was an official explanation
all right efren rios says luke i moved
to new hampshire thanks to your mention
of the free state project family is
loving it yeah it's a great
family-friendly place and a lot of great
people there fighting for freedom
fighting for personal responsibility and
working on a lot of really cool things
if you wanna if you wanna live in a
place with community
and uh you know strong familial bonds
and the right to teach your child he's a
flame thrower and new hampshire is the
place to be absolutely i don't know
florida has some i've seen some flame
throwing in florida and it's a little
they ban a bunch of stuff they banned
binary triggers in florida you can't
have that yeah there's a lot of strange
rules in florida especially when it
comes to red flag laws there's some
weird jurisdictions that uh are very
troubling so new hampshire definitely
takes the cake in in some instances
yeah i like new hampshire i think it's
still second to tennessee
tennessee is pretty freaking great yes
it is
there wouldn't be a texas without
tennessee by the way there you go
buttweasel says when is rumble going to
do super chats you do don't you yeah we
do rants but i think the question is why
don't we do it in the app
and oh i see and and that's
that's the interesting answer is that if
you do it in the app when on ios or
android they take 30 points from you we
charge 20. so imagine 30 plus 20 doesn't
look so good so right now it's web only
um you can do it on mobile web support
it on web desktop that's another
monopoly problem this is why netflix
tinder and all these other platforms
don't let you buy things on the app
stores because the app stores take a big
percentage of money away and only
android and apple are allowing the app
stores to be there and they take a huge
cut there is there has been some good
victories in the court that are leading
with the um
that game yeah well there's a big class
action that was just recently so i i
don't think this is going to last for
too long but we can't wait to put that
in when we can but like how can you be
competitive if youtube's charging 30 and
they own android they don't have to give
a [ __ ] right
howard says anyone buying bitcoin right
now fyi on tesla read the 10ks
anyone buying bitcoin what do you think
luke um
it's it's it's crazy out there well it
depends on why you buy it if you're
buying it for short term speculative
purposes that's high risk but if you're
buying it as an alternative currency to
have to fight the fed and to fight the
central banks then it's a good idea i
still think i'm not selling you know
it's funny because someone tweeted at me
they're like not talking about bitcoin
now are you and i'm like i've talked
about bitcoin like basically every day
because the crash happened i mean it's
just it's
talk about it same as i normally do i'm
not selling any of it i just i
it crashes i've seen this i've seen
worse i mean george gammon who's really
good in the economic space has been
saying forever it's going to go up and
down but buy it for long-term value if
you're looking at it from a speculative
value but really buy it because it gives
you an alternative security i call it
sort of plan b you know you know it's
heat you know have you have something in
your life that you can walk out on in 15
seconds flat if you feel the heat around
the corner from the movie heat you
should be prepared if the system comes
knocking on your door that you can exit
when and where and how you want and part
of that is going to be bitcoin you can't
be completely dependent on the u.s
banking system if you want to be secure
yeah
david c cronk senior says a red-pilled
gavin newsom might actually have a
chance in 2024. by the way that maybe
why he's doing what he's doing it's not
going to be red pill but he's wanting to
replace kamala harris and joe biden yep
that that's why he's trying to seem more
of like a moderate yeah and he's he's
doing anything to get attention to
himself he survived it and it was real
smart yeah getting on truth social we
talked about it everybody knows biden's
gonna be replaced everybody knows harris
has hated he thinks of himself as the
next president he imagines himself as a
kennedy which is a disgrace yeah
all right
mass jenna
mass gen okay her name is jenna but it's
jenna's side very clever says there was
a weeping and gnashing of teeth as i
sent off my self-employed quarterly
payment i couldn't help but think of
luke rydkowski taxes are thefts
inflationary stuff too yup combine the
two and you're really hit come come to
canada you get the pay
50 tax and you still get the same
inflation you got here
all right
what do you think you'll escape
all that i know is i've been paying a
lot of tax and it's it's a fortunate
thing to be able to pay tax
but my goodness you didn't realize you
were working for the government fifty
percent of the time that's crazy mm-hmm
fifty percent it's like 53. yeah well
it's 40 40 somewhat
then you got your property tax then you
got your sales tax then you got your
license then you got you got all these
incidentals you're paying for every
dollar you make you're paying more than
50 cents to the government if you make
over a certain amount the mafia wants
their money
it's legalized it's legalized mafia and
you got to pay in advance also you got
to pay before you even make the money
people people serenity serenity sorry i
can't wait till rumble merges and
becomes american
oh yeah
when uh uh you know starting a company
and then figuring out how corporate
taxes are paid i was just like
but i don't have that like they you
gotta pay advance you gotta you gotta
you gotta pay based on what they think
you might have but you made the last
year quarterly payments in advance and
it's you know
and if you're doing worse too bad yeah
well they'll give you a credit at the
end of the year you know how i i'm still
waiting it doesn't matter well if you
ever realize
really good tax law you don't have to
pay much of it at all but that's another
if you have a good accountant
we should talk barnes
[Laughter]
i know a few people all right sweet lou
says we say channels on the right but
that includes all of the middle of the
road truth seekers that get bundled in
his right wing because they don't toe
the line of leftists love the hair viva
is that exactly it like we had dennis
prager on and he's talking about how
he's a liberal but he's a conservative
because he talks about facts and reason
and logic and things like and morality
viva was a youtube uh video award winner
oh yeah before it became the show i i
got the shorty award the show the shorty
social good award back in the day it'll
never happen again
it'll never happen
i'm the shorty award winner for the best
journalist in social media i believe
2012.
and that's not that there's anything
less good about the shorty social good
awards but it was the new version of
their sort of social their shorty awards
that's big time stuff i think i got
kicked out of the shorty awards for
confronting somebody there but i forgot
to
so i have that yeah
all right
it was in the new york times building i
remember that the part the party was
good yeah i went i went down yeah i got
kicked out of that
dylan sharp says on the topic of
censorship and having two canadians in
the house can we get their thoughts on
bill c-11 and how it'll change media and
how it could be a template for blue
states to follow
uh it's a template to turn canada into a
a china or north korea it's the bill
c-11 in the absolute nuttiest of
nutshells is uh regulating the internet
the way the government already regulates
television and radio so they want to
subject they want to subject
they said initially streaming in like
big platforms online to be governed by
the canada broadcast act which imposes
canadian content requirements uh fines
if you don't comply with it they want to
impose that on the internet to force
youtube and social media to
uh suppress or promote content based on
its canadian content criteria
uh it is nothing other than a disguised
attempt to re-establish a flailing
legacy media on a platform where they
are getting crushed by others based on
their merit that's all that it is it's
crazy when you have like big tech
fighting the canadian government against
this bill
and you have washington post fighting
canada on this spell
it just shows you how
how horrible it really is you got
youtube is is fighting is complaining
about it everyone knows but then you get
bell canada coming and testifying for
the liberals oh we need this we got to
protect canadian culture from the guy
who says we don't have culture and we
don't have a canadian culture justin
trudeau said there is no canadian
culture that's crazy because you got uh
was it tim hortons that what it's called
we got maple syrup man
70 of the global exports that's right we
got fishing we got hunting we have sorry
we've got soar we got a boot we got a
boot we've got a canadian culture but
they only care about it when they can
tax you for it but i mean in all
seriousness you know suri in a boot are
literally canadian culture it's it's
it's a cultural phenomenon poutine uh
it's called tim hortons right tim
hortons was the famous hockey player
died in a drunk driving car accident
most people don't know that but uh it
became a chain and the tim hortons no
apostrophe on it also another part of
canadian heritage because french laws in
quebec don't allow or didn't allow the
time the apostrophe and so tim hortons
didn't want to have to have two
brandings so they just eliminated the
apostrophe huh oh wow but there's no
you have language police yeah most
certainly do yeah
the olf the language police they come in
they come and make sure if you have an
apostrophe you better have a trademark
wasn't a parrot arrested for uh
misgendering their child father yeah the
parents were arrested for misgendering
the child it was it more complicated
than that british columbia but their
human rights tribunal it was like a
father who refused to call
he
had disclosed
information not available
child celebrity
mike ward made a joke about this kid
named jeremy gabriel who suffers from
treacher colin syndrome he had a
stand-up bit about him
the kid sued him in human rights court
wow government takes up the case when
they decide it's legitimate and uh the
court fined the comedian forty three
thousand dollars it went all the way to
the supreme court five to four decision
they said no
it's not a human rights violation so he
ended up winning he ended up winning
years later stress later all this other
stuff but yeah we can all right brad
burns says will rumble make money though
google can just let youtube run at a
loss but hosting is expensive how will
this not just be gone in a few years
like any other youtube alts that came
and went that's a great question
um
so one of the things that we're we're
really focused on right now is obviously
the the growth of the users um and in
the future revenue but uh i can
definitely say
the
the audience that's on rumble converts
for advertisers at a pace that i have
never seen before prior to like this uh
conservative audience coming onto rumble
like pre 2020
our cpms with advertisers were
significantly lower and now the audience
that we're having right now we have
sponsors coming to us that are saying
that we're converting at a rate that is
so significantly higher than what
they're seeing on other platforms
um that they are renewing and spending
at a rate that uh you know we haven't we
haven't seen before so
i don't believe that to be true actually
i know that not to be true is that the
revenue model on rumble is actually
going to far exceed i think what people
are are anticipating because the
audience there
buys it's a it's a parallel economy it
it it is and like not only is it just a
parallel economy but like
the the purchase power of the audience
on rumble is
you see it you see it with creators on
rumble salty cracker will generate tons
of
of super chats these these people have
wallets and they can spend money it's
it's happening and and you just need to
go and go on a rumble and take a look
and you'll see it for your own your own
self it it's there the economy is there
and it's it it's mind-blowing like i
just had like this week alone the orders
that we're seeing on the ad side was
just mind-blowing of how happy the
advertisers are and how much it's
converting on an roi basis this is not
brand advertisers these are companies
looking for roi and they're getting
immediate roi when buying on rumble when
we when we launch rumble ads both on the
display the video in sponsorships um on
our platform which is in beta right now
we've actually started letting people in
in the last week for the first time um i
think we're going to see some some well
i already can see that we're seeing some
incredible results well i can see places
like youtube struggling because i mean
they put tyson food ads on our stuff and
i you know i have a tennessee blood oath
against tyson foods so the uh there's
nobody that's watching us that's buying
tyson foods but because i mention it
frequently they're frequently the
advertising on youtube and now that you
mentioned it i've been noticing
coalition avenir de quebec advertising
which is the the government in quebec
that i have been calling supreme leader
francoise for the last two years running
ads on my videos as if anybody i tell
everyone let the ad run make them pay
premium youtube whatever and then go
vote against them
uh no but i was gonna say or a cpm just
for anyone who doesn't know cost per
mill which is uh the amount per thousand
views and roi return on investment
when uh bloomberg was dumping money into
youtube ads i kept getting comments from
people being like hey i got a bloomberg
and i was like that's great he's paying
me to rag on him that's fantastic but
let's be real it really doesn't make
sense bloomberg wants to put ads on
videos critical of him so that he can
get his message in front of it
i end up getting money knowing my
audience would never vote for the guy so
thanks for the money i guess
yeah and i think it's because
there's aspects to which this system
because going back to your original
point that what rumble is doing by
becoming the free space on the internet
uh is ultimately a money winner is what
counters all of this and it's because
youtube's decision is a money loser over
time so suppressing and censoring speech
is not a desirable outcome for its
audience
i totally agree and we're we're seeing
it like the
they've given away their
incredibly high value audience and it's
it and it's growing and the purchase
power is there it's us-based it's they i
don't think they realize what they've
lost
i really don't um i i i can see it from
my side they lost something they they
lost something very
very important
yeah man well
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and head over to timcast.com we're gonna
have that after hours
uncensored not so family-friendly
version of the show coming up at about
11 p.m so you'll definitely want to
check that out you can follow the show
at timcast irl follow us on instagram we
post clips follow me at timcast viva you
want to shout anything out uh viva fry
on youtube and rumble the viva from
twitter and
vivabarnslaw.locals.com did you want to
shout anything anything else out robert
uh no other than the locals thing and
just a shout out to i mean the people
that they ask questions about you can
follow jacob drazen the duran on youtube
uh all the greats uh independent sources
on ukraine and world news richard barris
people's pundit the only accurate
pollster in the last half decade all
those are great guys to follow right on
you can find me on truth at chris and
you can follow rumble on truth at rumble
barnes uh when i'm in jail i'm calling
you uh just a heads up i think i said
this last time to you but every time you
come on i'm like i need him
he said when i'm in jail not yet
it's only a matter of time until we're
all in the gulag so just wait for it and
if you want to find out more about me
and what i'm doing you can check out my
platform lookuncensored.com
i've been doing it for a number of years
now i got a lot of crazy stuff up there
we also use rumble now and uh thank you
chris for coming on thank you for uh
listening to the audience thank you for
for taking the tough questions i i think
it's really important for uh people to
be transparent and open and i think uh
you've done that in a good way so thank
you so much for coming on and uh thank
you for having me a part of the
conversation
yeah absolutely thank you guys all so
much for coming elon musk made this
tweet go viral you guys should go watch
what he has to say because it does seem
like he kind of wanted this to be like
he's saying a lot of really good things
about free speech a lot of really
encouraging stuff anyway i will not be
shamed for loving sour patch kids i
don't care what's in them it's candy you
eat it because it's fun not because it's
good for you and you guys can follow me
on twitter and mines.com at
sourpatchlist as well sourpatch lid stop
me it's a poison a couple a couple
things you can check out
you can check out the song will of the
people that uh i made we put it out just
before the election in 2020 and uh we
got a big billboard for it in times
square we're gonna be putting out an
album probably the next couple of months
so stay tuned for that you can check out
youtube.comcastcastle we've brought on
jamie kilstein to help take the vlog to
the next level and we're doing comedy
bits and the goal is to make it very
much like a weird vlog hybrid comedy
skit show so it's a fictionalized
version of the studio we've done a few
bits over the past a year or so but now
we're gonna start cranking it up and
getting in full swing and other than
that thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all over at timcast.com for that
members-only show
you